e
e e
I'd like to welcome every to today's
education committee uh hearing uh we
have a hearing uh that's uh regarding a
Amendment 811h which is a non-gain
amendment to S SP 340 prior to getting
into that I'd like to welcome everybody
back back and I hope you had a wonderful
weekend they usually are exhausting it's
Pleasant to get back here where we can
sit down and relax a little bit maybe uh
so with that I have representative
cordelli who is the Prime sponsor of
this amendment 1811 H this amendment is
s SP 340 and um on that
Amendment I'd like to
read what that Amendment
does it's public hearing on proposed non
gerain Amendment
20241 1811 H2
sb340 it's relative to communication
between parents and school districts
regarding special education this
amendment would provide that the school
district May provide information
regarding a child's special education
program by electronic mail unless the
parent elects to receive such
information by US
mail expand certain uh special education
reporting requirements by local
districts the Department of Education
and the advocate for Special Education
Direct the Department of Education and
advocate for special education to enter
into a memorandum of understanding
regarding access to Student Records
maintained by the department and finally
and provide the that administrative
rules regarding special education shall
not exceed state or federal minimum
requirements unless specifically
authorized by Statute copies the
amendment are available uh on the table
I believe over there unless they've all
been taken uh somebody needs a copy we
can make a copy for you so with that
representative cordelli welcome thank
you very much um for the record uh Glenn
cordelli representing Tuftonboro
wolfboro and oopy in the beautiful Lakes
Region and it's a pleasure to uh
introduce uh non Germaine Amendment 1811
H um this is really uh a response to the
due process audit that uh we went
through um a week or so ago um and it's
the uh outp put of work uh between
several of us uh along with the
specialed advocate and the Department of
Education uh four or five different
people from the Department of Education
so there's um a lot of work that has
gone into this uh this amendment um I'd
like to go through it a little bit
briefly and also tie it uh to the audit
if I
can uh the first section on page one uh
starting on line nine is um the original
SB 340 that's section one uh section two
down starting on line
23 uh gets into uh current statute
related to uh an annual report uh on
special education from from the
department and the first uh change there
you'll see on line 26 is just putting in
a date that that uh annual report is
required
going over to uh page
two um in uh number four uh we just
update the uh federal law reference um
No Child Left Behind has been uh
replaced by the every excuse me every
student succeeds act so that's um one
change there then uh there's a new
number
five and this is um quite important and
that um we don't really have a good
handle on the number of
IEPs that have not been signed off on by
parents or partially signed off on by
parents so there
is uh great possibility for students not
getting the services that they need
because of those I EP refusals and we
don't really have any good numbers on
them um except uh via some work that uh
the special education Advocate has done
so this indicates that we need to know
the number and category of those
refusals and also track the resolution
of when those um IEPs uh are resolved
and see what the timeline is there are
um refused IEPs that go for over a year
um and have uh great implications for
those children that are um in need of
services um and this ties
into um the audit um on page five there
is a summary um that includes um this um
aspect um observation one on page
27 relates specifically to this uh in
terms of uh oversight and in internal
controls um also on table two on page 29
um it is referenced um in uh that
table uh observation three on page 35
um this is also referenced in terms of
uh planning and
organization um I think uh there was two
more references that I'd like to site um
observation nine on page
65 did
indicates um that the increasingly
complex resolution processes and ad hoc
rules um compromise parental
rights and finally
on page 88 there is option excuse me
observation number
15 um which also uh relates to the need
for data and Reporting so we know what's
going on and we if we don't know what's
going on we don't have the data to um
justify actions then um it it's hard to
make change we need the data and we need
to know what's going on
um I I see a number of U bills uh coming
next year as an uh output uh from this
audit and the next special education
audit that due by the end of the
year um going down to line 20 um we get
into the office of special
education and um uh I couldn't be
happier that we have this um office and
uh really at this point a oneperson
office uh in place because they are
actually um really helping families
rather than handing out manuals as other
organizations do um they are actually
helping families navigate the process
and work with departments uh to get
services so on line uh
20 um we talk about the need for Access
of information um for the special
education Advocate and um put into
statute that the department and The
Advocate uh shall enter are into a memo
of understanding mou uh related to uh
access to Student Records uh maintained
by the department um the current system
in place um for most of these records um
has uh historical data going back um I'd
say to the beginning of time but not
quite that long uh but um for a long
time and um I think theou is needed to
work out agreement between the
department and special ed
Advocate and then down on line
28 um there are reports that The
Advocate is required by law uh to
produce uh annually and um the
department has agreed to work with the
uh Advocate to pull data from the
databases um so that the uh Advocate can
comply with um her duties per
law uh going down to the bottom of the
page um we get into uh Ru making and I
think this is um been the discussion U
for uh quite a while in terms of um uh
the rules that are in place um I have a
chart if anyone's interested um a spread
sheet of um where our rules uh
comply with federal law or state law um
and some uh explanation but I I think
that there are people doing a a deeper
dive into that do um our rule are our
rules actually less restrictive or more
restrictive than federal law there is
debate about that and so I think that we
need to take a a deeper dive into that
um and it's important to note that this
section relates to observations 9 10 and
11 beginning on page
65 um where it talks about
um Federal requirements
not implemented in rules it talks about
uh the um imposition of ad hoc rules and
unenforceable informational requirements
that compromise parents rights as we've
heard um again uh
previously um we go over to uh page
67 and uh the lack of controls to make
sure that leas are local districts are
timely implementing and following
Federal
requirements and that um federal law
also requires the state to enforce and
monitor what's going on in those um
those
districts um and it goes on uh to page
68 um with recommendations from uh the
audit about um ensuring uh rules
accurately ref reflect and interpret all
federal
requirements that in the audit um and it
goes on for several more pages with
several important um uh Provisions um
included there and I would just like to
read that um from our administrative
procedure
act which defines a rule as rules
adopted by an agency
to a Implement interpret or make
specific statutory in forced or
administered by an
agency rules are supposed to
reflect statute federal or state
statute
um not go beyond federal or state
statute so uh you know I I look at our
special ed statutes that we have in rsas
and I think um they're pretty uh pretty
thin in my view um and I think we need
to work um on uh really putting more
into statute um in uh New
Hampshire
um then another very important section
uh six follows that and
this provides for local districts to
come up with their own disp
resolution uh procedures so it can vary
from District to District you know you
might talk to a neighbor down the street
about a dispute resolution and they have
a completely different process in their
local school district um it can add
great confusion uh for parents and
really makes it a freefor
all so what we do here is say that they
may
develop you know I have a difference of
opinion there but um the amendment says
they may develop uh dispute resolutions
locally but those plans must be
submitted to the Department of Education
for review that's in line nine on page
three it's important that the department
knows what's going on and then in Roman
2 below
that
um it requires districts to sub shall
submit information related to these
alternate dispute resolution processes
um each year including the topic of the
of the dispute and the resolution again
we need data to find out if these uh
dispute resolution practices that are
being implemented in District a versus
District B Etc are actually having any
impact are they producing results and if
they are producing results Maybe we
should um uh look at including them in
statute as part of our dispute
resolution
processes um and that relates to page
excuse me observation number 16 on pages
93 and also there's a very important uh
reference to that on um page
71 so I think
that that's a a brief look look at the
amendment and how we've tried to address
the uh audit and the audit
recommendations um and the need to put
this forward as a non-main Amendment so
that we can get things started we cannot
wait another year to start addressing
this audit um so I uh thank you very
much for your time thank you very much
represent cordelli are there questions
yes representative
luno thank you very much Mr chair and
thank you very much representative
cordelli for um um for your time this
morning on this but I want to pick on
something you just said um you just said
quote it's important that the department
knows what's going on and and I want to
read directly from the um the audit
report yep that that came out um
recently on this very subject um right
on page
27 and there's similar
um statements uh found in the audit
report but what it says on um on page 27
is um Department of Education oversight
of internal controls was ineffective
management did not adequately design
implement or monitor special education
dispute resolution process controls
existing controls were limited informal
inconsistently updated and clearly
documented or communicated instead
management not the legislature
management relied significantly on staff
institutional knowledge to carry out
operation operations this was ineff uh
insufficient to ensure consistent and
effective operations or reduce
organizational knowledge loss risk these
were known risks during the audit period
which likely existed for many years
there were no strategies plans policies
or procedur procedures for supporting
decisions and managing dispute
resolution processes records and
databases supporting processes were
inadequate and staff turnover occurred
all of which contributed to operational
defic deficiencies and knowledge loss so
what did this management incompetence
lead to it led to and this again is from
the uh the audit report non-compliance
with or unenforced requirements at the
state and local level untimeliness
untimeliness with dispute resolution
process time limits and related
reporting requirements unmitigated risks
such as conflicts of interest fraud and
waste unaddressed longstanding issues
identified in Prior evaluations or
audits resource constraints limited and
inaccurate output data and a lack of
public transparency so when when I read
that and and that the that the leading
contributing factors to the state's
complete failure in um in in having a
sufficient and um and and appropriate uh
dispute resolution prop um process for
special education falls on management
not on the legislature is there a
question yeah in in in fact yes in fact
if you look at the the the um the
observation review it cites 20
observations 16 of them saying no
legislative action is
required and on the ones that uh that
you have cited specifically such as
observation number nine um it says no OB
no legislative action is require
required so why do um do do you feel
that legislative action is required uh
when uh when it's it's very clear from
the report that this is a failure on the
part of
management um I'm
still was was that a question I guess
leg action why do you feel legislative
action is required when the failure
clearly rests um on the shoulders of
management I think that um uh maybe you
uh go a little bit uh far with uh
placing uh blame for the problems in
special education um I think that uh um
there are uh um many uh contributing
factors to the problems we've seen in
special education uh
um we've tried to address some with
legislation this this performance audit
and next let me give you some background
um we have a lot of people who haven't
seen this but this started about five
years ago with a bill I put in for um
Shifting the burden of proof in due
process hearings from the uh parent to
the school district someone on the
committee wanted to replace the bill
with a St study
committee so I did an amendment and
added the study committee to my bill
which passed and got signed into law we
had the study committee um it was
chaired by former Senator Reagan um I
think uh chairman lad was on that study
committee as well uh uh chairman uh
Reagan happened to also be chair of the
legislative performance audit committee
at the time and so one of our
recommendations from that study
committee was performance
audit um and that also led to
legislation to create the office of the
special education advocate so um looking
at our statutes also
um they are quite thin and do not uh
reflect What's um in the rules in many
cases uh and neither does federal law so
I think we have to if we're going to
have things in rules they have to be
based on statute federal or state so we
have to look at both the rules and the
um
statutes um in terms of the department
um you yourself read uh about the uh the
turnover um we've heard about um whether
um additional uh Staffing is required in
the department uh in the specialed area
um and that is a legislative um option
that's available in terms of the next
budget that we need to look at um so I
don't think that you and as you said
also this goes back years um you know I
remember hearing about problems um when
I started in 2012 so this is uh nothing
new new but we have to start really
taking a hard look at things and I think
we are trying to do that with this um uh
amendment that addresses things in the
performance audit and hopefully there'll
be more legislation coming next year
also that will address things that are
pointed out in the uh next special
education audit because this this
performance audit was just about due
process there's a lot more out there and
we need to dig into that and find
Solutions follow up quickly quick thank
you very much Mr chair so um you you you
you started off saying that that maybe I
went a little bit too far so I was
reading directly from the report uh the
the the qu I guess the two parts of this
question did the report go too far is
that what you're saying and then the
second part is the specifically the the
the first piece that I read was
Department of Education oversight of
internal controls was ineffective
management did not adequately design
implement or monitor special education
dispute resolution process controls
controls are the rules so if the if the
department is
ineffective at at at implementing and
enforcing the rules how does changing
the rules
matter so did the report go too far is
that what you're saying and how does
changing the rules make any
difference uh no the report did not go
too far in terms of identifying issues
um and certainly there are uh issues in
the department that need to be addressed
but um also I think that this is built
up over time with
people well meaning rules and uh reports
and um manuals maybe that um the process
in New Hampshire is so complex maybe we
need to simplify things a little bit um
and that falls on the department and us
um uh
with local process for for due process
resolution um in addition to State um we
have we have state processes um uh
neutral conferences for instance um
we've had three neutral conferences in
three years maybe we should simplify
things um to make it easier for parents
so U will making things simpler uh help
in terms of management controls in the
department I think so but part of that
also falls on us and um not just uh good
intentions but it's time for good
actions
also thank you very much I have I have a
question for you um having done a little
bit of work on this myself I'm I'm very
very concerned about our database that
we have at the Department of
Education and if the special education
Advocate is trying to find information
in the aggregate of what's occurred in X
year going back back back and we know
there's well hundreds of thousands of
Records in that that
database and it's not accessible due to
some of the Privacy rights of those that
have IEPs in there who may now be 30y
olds adults so my my concern is would
the local level and due process being a
little bit different in many of these
districts how much of this information
is now located not just in that database
but at the local
level uh I I think quite a bit um
because I it is my understanding there
are even uh a few districts do not
participate in that
database um which is an issue and I I
think that the department is looking to
address uh the shortcomings um of that
database um it was something that I had
wanted to put into the amendment
um but uh based on indications that the
department is looking at addressing um
those problems um I did not um but uh
the special ed Advocate is charged in
law for um going into the districts and
having access to the local records um
themselves um this uh was trying to
relate just to that database that you
described that has thousands and
thousands of historical records in it
and um maybe records that are not needed
for the current work of The Advocate um
and that's we were close to agreement on
specific language but um in order to uh
meet deadlines um we left it with u anou
to be signed um related to that by the
department with the advocate thank you
further questions representative
Woodcock thank you Mr chairman U Mr
chairman I have three questions for
clarification if I
mayell thank you for taking the
hopefully uh on page three uh I'm
looking at the line nine that you
identify where it talks about the local
school district creating a plan that
shall be submitted to department for
review me m okay and then
what um that's what we try and address
here and the plans they have are to be
provided shall be provided to the
department along with uh the timeline
the topic of the dispute and the
resolution if any so that the department
can capture that data and see if um
those processes that are in place are
working or not but thank you but going
the same question so two're going to the
same question but if you're going back
to the start of that 789 it talks about
that the local school district can
create their own and just give it the de
so it doesn't they don't have to be
consistent with anything
particularly and doe May provide
assistance of ask but if not it's just
another document going forward that's
different from one school district uh to
another um in in the amendment we change
that to the the plan uh shall be uh
submitted to the Department for review
and the department shall provide
technical assistance to the school
district yeah in develop if they ask for
it and implementing doesn't say they
it's sort of like creating a plan and
going to the doe and just put it in
another file the second question I may
Mr chair I have three um thank you and
this is why I don't understand uh I'm on
page three reverent cordelli uh lines uh
two and three to talk about the state
board rules and the federal minimum and
state statute and I understand you're
talking about the need to have uh
structure that has um statute Follow by
rules uh but my question is four things
that are currently in place now today
that are providing educational special
Educational Services does that mean then
that services that youngsters are
getting today may be reduced
uh I do not believe so no there nothing
in here about um reducing um uh or
changing or um uh eliminating um rules
um at this
point that same point Mr chair thank you
but it said they can adop rule that
exceed state of federal minimum I got
that but my question is if they already
are exceeding services are exceeding
state or federal minimum does that mean
this passes that those youngster service
has been R reduced no it does not no um
and every 10 years the department um
re-evaluates rules and at that point um
when that comes up um we could take a
look at that but I think in the meantime
we have to make sure that our state
statutes also reflect what we want uh to
be going on um um for instance I could I
finish please please um in
2015 the um
legislature passed on the consent
calendar and signed into law repealing
of the facilitated IEP team
meetings but they're still going on
so we have to make sure that state
statutes uh reflect what we want to
happen uh are there too many due process
options you know we've heard that in
testimony when we're going over the
audit report I think so um such as the
neutral conference um we have to align
rules with statute and where our
statutes are short and do not reflect um
uh best practices and what we want to
happen uh to Aid families then we have
to address that legislatively as well
as administratively with rules I I would
just comment to that do you have one
more question I do can we jump to that
one quickly because I we got a lot of
people wanting to speak okay I was
responding to the audit which said
clearly we aren't doing best practices
that's not happening that's pretty clear
uh my last question if I may is was this
were these amendments generated uh and
created by you by the doe or by a
different organization uh um this is
about the 14th or 15th draft of an
amendment um that have been reviewed by
four or five people uh in the department
including the Deputy Commissioner okay
um and the special Advocate um legal
staff in the department um so it has
been a uh collaborative effort uh to
arrive at uh Amendment 1811 thank you
thank you I might add this special
education Advocate was also involved in
this process thank you sir yeah further
questions from the
committee thank you very much uh due to
the number of cards which we have here
we have about 25 cards here uh I'm going
to limit limit the length of speaking to
three minutes if we in fact start
rolling on here too far I'll have to
even reduce that but so initially we're
going to start with a three minute time
limit and I'd like to invite up Bonnie
Dunham
good
morning I just I think I turned it off
I'm terribly sorry um could we start the
clock
over than I'll give you seven seconds
thanks um so I'm here as a mom um and I
live in mirac New Hampshire both my son
and I benefited from the protections and
the New Hampshire rules and it's sad
that this amendment would mean that
future children with disabilities and
their families won't have the same
rights and protections that we did it is
unbelievably disappointing that an
amendment this important was introduced
with just days notice and most parents
didn't even know that it existed so much
for PR parent involvement every other
time our state rules were reviewed it
was done through a thoughtful and very
open process number of years ago when
our statute and rules were revised a 33
person work group including parents
legislators SCH School Personnel um
reviewed them in detail line by line it
was led by Senator Nancy Styles and it
was re and consensus was reached on
almost everything um RSA 186c says that
it's hereby declared to be the policy of
the state that the rights of children
with disabilities and their parents are
protected this amendment does the exact
opposite of that it it defies the whole
purpose of RSA 186c it takes away rights
from children and their parents idea was
never intended to be a sealing it was a
floor it was the starting point States
can't go below the minimum requirements
in idea um but they are expected to
develop rules that comply with idea as
New Hampshire does while reflecting the
state's values and I don't believe that
the audit intended to engage in
wholesale dismantling of special
education rights um RSA 186c gives the
Board of Education the responsibility to
make rules that implement the statute
which is why they're more detailed they
have to adopt rules related to
developing IEPs approving and monitoring
programs due process hearings
eligibility determination surrogate
parents and other matters um related to
complying with a statute so that's
exactly what they did um for example in
defining a child with a dis ility RSA
186c says the child must be evaluated by
a school district according to rules
adopted by the State Board of Education
that's it it doesn't say who evaluates
them the requirements for the
evaluations how long it can take the
rights of parents to participate and who
decides whether the child is a child
eligible for special education and how
that happens so of course they're more
detailed the New Hampshire rules support
meaningful parent involvement in the
process they make the process more
efficient proactive and clear they
protect students from hiring and they
provide accountability and trans and
transparency they include clear
timelines 10 days 14 days not a
reasonable time or enough time who knows
what that might mean um they don't cost
anything they're a sound business
practice they require leas to provide
parents with evaluation and assessment
reports at least 5 days before a meeting
so they don't show up at a meeting get
handed a packet of evaluation results be
expected to review them and
simultaneously use that information are
you kidding me that's three that that's
three minutes and 7 Seconds did you did
you start it over pardon
me you did start it over your your
time's up okay um I submitted written
testimony a lot of written testimony I
saw that come by yes yeah yeah thank you
very much are there any questions
represent
leus I thank you for taking my question
I understand your concerns I do note
that in here it say provided that in no
case the State Board uh adopt a role
that exceeds and to me that's a future
in the future that they don't exceed not
that they retroactively take out rules
but the other thing
is um unless the rule is specifically
authorized by Statute and I believe the
intent is
to create those statutes which there
wasn't time for this year for this you
know since the came to come up with all
those statutes but would you be willing
or interested since you have a huge
bunch of information of what those are
in helping to figure out what statutes
need to be put in next
year in order to um codify all of those
things so that we're not losing anything
in the future so first of all in terms
of everything we have now being safe the
next time the rules are reviewed then it
goes away so we've bought a little time
but that's that's not the answer I would
suggest having a committee a diverse
committee come together before you
dismantle special education rights and
see what needs to be added to the
statute why not just start with saying
everything in the rules is now in the
statute next year we'll decide what to
get rid
of thank you very much representative
Woodcock thank you good morning thank
you for coming and providing this detail
report can you give me one sentence uh
your evaluation of this
amendment section
five right it is stunningly dangerous
for
families mind-bogglingly bad thank you
further
questions thank you very much I want to
remind the public that we're here not
testifying on the original 340 which was
basically electronic communications with
a parent we're talking about an
amendment to that so let's keep it to
the amendment uh Karen
Rosenberg good morning members of the
committee chairman La thank you for
having me I'm the my name is Karen
Rosenberg I'm the policy director at the
disability right Center and I'm here to
testify in strong opposition to the non-
gerine amendment that's before you my
testimony is going to focus on Section
Five which is the section that Bonnie
Dunham was just addressing and not and
but you shouldn't take absence of
comments as agreeing that the rest of
the amendment is fine it's just not with
so little time there wasn't time to
really analyze the entire Amendment um
we already have in place a process by
which all administrative agencies rules
are vetted by the legis ISL so that is
what the joint legislative committee on
administrative rules does that's their
job they are in place to make sure that
when a state agency chooses to amend its
rules that it complies with public
notice and opportunities for public
participation and that the rules are
within the authority of the state agency
and if they are not within the state
agency's Authority then the committee
may enter an objection a fi a
preliminary and a final objection and
basically take the agency to task to
make sure that they have the authority
and that the rules that they are
promulgating are in the best interest of
the public and meet all the other
requirements so the current education
rules as Miss dham testified yes do some
of them exceed the federal minimums they
do and it's permissible and J car has
found that that the agency was acting in
accordance with its Authority and these
rules that exceed the federal minimum
are incredibly important to enable
parents to participate in their
children's
education when children are evaluated
whether to determine their eligibility
for education or to determine their
continuing eligibility and what they
need to get a free appropriate education
there are a bunch of evaluations that
are done and parents get a stack of
evaluation reports that are written by
experts and they need time to review
those to understand to meaningfully
participate in the process this is just
one rule that exceeds okay our rules
give parents that opportunity this
amendment would strip parents of that
opportunity or at the very least make it
impossible for the Department to
promulgate another rule that would give
parents the opportunity to review
evaluations before a meeting just just
one um with unless the legislature
passed a statute enabling this rule to
exist this rule is completely within the
purview of Education it's been vetted by
hundreds of people hundreds of hours and
was determined to be within the
authority of the state agency other
things that our rules do our rules
require timelines when a parent is
concerned about their children's
education program and wants to have a
team meeting our rules require once they
receive a written notice for the team to
get back to the parent within 14 days is
that 14-day period required in federal
law no is it within the authority of the
agency and within keeping of Our
obligation under current state and
federal law to provide a faap yes I
guess my time is up
yes it is thank
you
technology got a l are there
questions rep San
Luna thank thank you very much uh Mr
chair and thank you very much um um M
Rosenberg for taking my question do do
you do you think that um that that um
you know reducing these um these rights
and stripping parents of Rights and
stripping um um special education
students of of Rights would um would I
mean does that make it easier I guess
for the um for the Department of
Education to uh avoid findings like this
and and to comply with like less well
thank you for the question I actually
don't see that at all I think it makes
it easier for the dep Department of
Education to monitor whether parents are
adequately involved and whether and
whether the education process is
continuing the way it ought to be under
federal law and to meet our federal
obligations because it provides
safeguards for parents along the way to
get notice of Team meetings to negotiate
when these should be to participate
adequately the department has to my
knowledge this is not really the problem
with the Department the department may
need more staff to implement policies I
think what I heard is that there was a
lot of turnover I don't think stripping
parents of Rights is going to further
the objectives of the corrective actions
recommended in the audit okay good thank
thank you very much thank very much
represent
belshire thank you Mr chair and thank
you for being here uh for your testimony
I think I have a basic understanding of
the problem that you bring up I want to
do a little more research to help better
understand whether we're dealing with an
issue that
is something to do with executive rulem
that would fall under sort of a Chevron
Doctrine issue or whether there was a
issue that
was established in state and federal law
where certain authorities were granted
for rulemaking that can be legally
exceeded by the executive so can you
either now or or sometime provide me
with some specific references to law
that I can look at uh for this I I want
to make sure I understand boy when you
said Chevron I think I had a law school
PTSD
moment sure uh just are you looking for
you want to so our current law um
provides author in various places for
the Department of Education to undergo
rule making so are you looking for those
particular Provisions yes exactly okay
so I think I can I can send you a quick
email that identifies what those
Provisions are thank you I appreciate
that let me just write myself a note to
do it repres laus do you have a
question thank you and I'm going to I'm
going to let you finish writing that
thank thank
you okay so it's sort of a follow on to
what I had asked earlier is that I don't
see that since since I don't see that
this bill is actually taking away rules
we already have it's saying in the
future we can't pass rules so when we go
and re-evaluate and redo our rules so my
question to you
is since we need to specifically
authorize them by Statute and I think
that's the point of this is that we need
to authorize those rules then you look
at the rules that are not currently
authorized by Statute and write us
something that explains why those
particular rule you know what the
purpose why they're good so that we can
come up with statute for next year to
cover those rules I think that's the
point of this legislation so I actually
think that all the rules we have in
place are already authorized under the
current statute and I think that what
the way that our government is
structured in terms of administrative
agencies and the role of administrative
agencies and the legislature is that the
legislature whether it's federal or
state delegates rulemaking Authority and
implementation authority to the agency
that is recognized as having the
expertise in that area because you know
the legislature is called upon to pass
overall overarching policies in a wide
range of areas right right not any one
of us can be have expertise in that such
a wide range of areas and so we have
administrative agencies that are in
place to adopt rules with a whole public
input um with public input requirements
and so I question whether it's really
appropriate for the for the legislature
to get into the minutia of every single
right and that I mean you if you've I
don't know if you've seen the rules that
currently exist um but there I I someone
here is going to like flash this book at
you but um which incl so many people
have them um I mean this would you would
be looking at using this legislative
process to get into the minutia of the
development of a evaluations and an
evaluation for you know every single
child in the state and then the other
thing to keep in mind is that sometimes
things change so polic other policies
that also impact a child's education
might change in other laws so for
example like your committee might not be
involved in Restraint and seclusion of
children with disabilities another
committee might and there's another and
there are now laws about that those also
impact students with disabilities with
there we have in our rules now a
Prohibition against the use of aversives
but you know that you know that that
preexisted the the current the most
recent change in the law and rules are
meant to be nimble they can you know if
there needs to be an emergency you know
something that needs to be addressed on
an emergency basis it can be so I really
you know theoretically would it be
possible representative leus you know
anything is possible I just don't think
it's really well advised to do that
thank you thank you
represent we have to really move on
we're we're really short in time here
represent Miler thank you Mr chair and
thank you m Mr Rosenberg for being here
and advocating for your constituents uh
based upon this report that we've all
received and uh have been briefed on by
the LBA on it the daming report
regarding the management uh of the um
dispute resolution process would it be
your position that based upon the issues
that been brought before us in this
report that it would be more prudent to
uh rather than dealing with this 11th
Hour Amendment uh to have an actual
study committee to look at this and be
more thorough in looking at this and on
the reports and the recommendations Etc
and then come forward with uh
legislation in the future would that be
your position to have a further study on
this on the implications of this and how
it might relate to legislative
initiatives thank you for the question
and I have a really short answer for you
yes
thank from from this point for what I'm
going to ask committee members ask one
question and we're going to pass it on
to somebody else okay so further
questions represent
perel thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question there's we've
already heard testimony now about um uh
parents rights students rights being
eliminated but I'm confused I don't know
if rights are established through the
rul making process where how is it that
parents rights are being removed I don't
I see this as a future
um section five in particular as um
using it for future rules unless the
rule is specifically authorized by
Statute so if you even taking that
reading of it I mean I'm not 100% sure
that that reading is accurate but let's
assume that that's true and that it
would only address future rules then you
are then we are on the precipice of
taking away some very very important
rights that are Central to a parent's
ability to participate and a child's
ability to secure a free appropriate
public education so I if if there is an
if this committee feels that there is a
need to adopt some more specific law
around the delivery of special education
for children that could be done in a in
the next legislative session and then
you know and and then it could be dealt
with in that way without putting these
rules at in Jeopardy or potential
Jeopardy thank you presid representa
Woodcock thank you chairman good morning
thank you for taking these number of
questions my one um representative cell
indicated this bill was pretty much
promulgated by the Department of
Education and all their Staffing and he
presented it um however his
interpretation of the part about minimum
standard is that nothing will be lost
for parents and students as we go
forward is that your interpretation I'm
I'm not 100% sure about that I mean I
haven't had very much time with this
amendment nor has anyone but I I am not
sure about that thank you further
questions from the committee thank you
Karen thank you uh Bob
Beville morning everyone thank you for
taking my testimony my name is Robert
bevel I live at 12 Blair Road marac New
Hampshire I want to thank repres
resentative cordelli and those people
who have worked on this amendment to
quickly try to get it in front of you uh
there are problems with it uh rather
than uh concentrating on Those portions
that are broken let's concentrate on the
pieces that work such for example in
section one it grants parents of all
school districts access to their
children's proposed IEPs and written
prior noce in electronic word searchable
PDF format I'm in the marac school
district I have had the benefit of
always getting a copy electronically I
can do word searches we can quickly
reference it this is a benefit I think
section one is good section two provides
for greater accountability based on the
March 2024 audit report in determining
special education revenues and
expenditures by the school district
along with better annual reporting of
progress and compliance for special ed
students across New Hampshire this is
good this is something we need to be
able to do is based on the audit report
hold the Department of Education
accountable for Revenue
expenditures grants those things so that
there is clear transparency on that
sections three and four provide better
Clarity for the reporting requirements
for the Department of Education provide
access to its nessus database and other
information within the department to the
newly created office of special
education advocate in order to better
support that office in its statutory
requirements to track and resolve
resolve uh resolutions of Ip disputes
sections 1 through four are excellent
here I understand what representative
cordelli is trying to do with Section
Five um he is right but because there is
confusion and inflammatory feelings on
this I think that section should be
stricken no rule grants greater rights
than statutes that's where we're here
rules create the process for how
statutes are done uh J clar has no teeth
it needs to have the ability to if it
doesn't like a rule stop a agency from
doing that Jake does not have the teeth
to do that right now I think that's what
they're trying to accomplish there uh
section six talks about creating yet
another um dispute resolutions we have
too many dispute resolutions processes
now we as the report recommended we need
to trim those Downs thank you very much
thank you are there any questions
representa
leus thank you um thank you for taking
my question there are two fives on here
there's the five that's in parentheses
that comes after the two three four then
we have that five which has nothing to
do with rules and whatever and then we
down farther there is a number five in
section two Roman numeral 2 which has
the rule making Etc so I'm
wondering you did not address
the in parentheses 5 up on line 10 there
down to the number five under Roman
numeral 2 and so I was wondering what
you thought of
those um again your committee time is
short I know that you guys are trying to
get as much possible done I'm trying to
focus on what representative cordelli
and you guys have got right in this
let's get it done uh I think the idea of
Leno's uh study committee I think about
looking at these we need to be able to
address this there's other legislation
before the committee I mean before the
legislature right now to completely
revamp education 200 education 1100 that
needs to be be addressed I was with
Bonnie in that hot summer in 2005 2006
where that um Bonnie took notes copious
notes I still have all of them she
worked very hard on the but it was not a
third parents a third legislators
representative style was there we had
three or four representatives there and
25 paid School administrators I didn't
get to pay get paid there uh the head of
the de education School charter school
was there a homeschooler mom a couple of
other peoples me and Bonnie we were it
and we were outvoted as the what
consensus for the rewriting of idea 2004
we're not going to be able to solve that
today we couldn't solve it over an
entire summer so uh again I'm looking at
the pieces that work today strike
sections five and six I think what he's
written in one through four meet two
things parts of the March 2024 audit
report and the statutory
responsibilities of the newly created
office of education Advocate she has
gotten nothing nothing from the
Department of Education for the requests
that are required by Statute and her
hands are tied there are angry parents
asking what's going on why can't she not
staff her office why are we not getting
answers why can she not look at the
databases that are required by Statute
this to me starts opening the door on
those we solve the rest of the problems
in the legislature later can can I just
get a clarification ma which which was
my original question which five are you
talking I'm talking about the five that
said Special Rule making amend RSA 18616
number eight so when you say strike five
that's the five you're talking yes ma'am
because I understand exactly what
representative is cordelli is trying to
do but because people are inflamed that
it means something else let's just
strike it and move on got it just than
representor pno thank you and thank you
for taking my question yes ma'am um it's
on my understanding that these special
education rules are up for review in
2025 is it possible that section 5 could
be proactive in terms of um evaluating
those rules when they come up
again I think it would be I think
because it is so so I had worked with
representative cordelli on on changing
the language of this to meet what was
part of observation number 11 starting
in page 73 talks about the
unaccountability in here and what it
needed to say was that any kind of rule
cannot exceed the department authority
of federal and state law that's what it
needed to be said it didn't rather than
trying to solve it on the back of a
Denny's napin right now let's just
strike it that's what I'm trying to say
I do think you're right we need to move
forward with that thank you thank you
further repres Woodcock thank you just I
my my apologies as you began I didn't
catch your uh relationship parent
administrator oh my goodness just just
one or two I have three children with
special needs um um I first got involved
at Bonnie's help and the governor
lynches in 2005 when there was a rewrite
of 186c I help advocate for parents I've
been involved in this for 17 years thank
you so much for eff apprciate it forther
questions thank you very much B thank
you very much Jane berson
good
morning there you go good morning my
name is Jane berson bulu I'm the
executive director for the New Hampshire
Association of special ed administrators
and I'm here representing over 270
leaders in the field field of special
education um we are here in opposition
of the bill uh as written the basis of
our opposition begins with the
Amendments brought forward that will
have a profound impact on New
Hampshire's children youth and families
the mission of our association is to
ensure that we provide high quality
education to our most complex students
and that we are a voice for equity and
excellence and
education when we we looked at the um
testimony our members brought forward um
several factors that I would like to
summarize for you first we'd like to
begin with the importance of the
legislative audit of special education
that's currently in process while the
findings of phase one of this audit have
been released we would strongly
encourage policy makers to have a
complete set of data and a comprehensive
set of recommendations prior to Bringing
forward any legislation members of our
association support and understand the
importance of the audit and would
strongly encourage a more deliberate
process while waiting for a
comprehensive report and
findings secondly we'd like to address
the removal of language from the New
Hampshire special education rules as it
pertains to exceeding state and federal
minimum requirements unless um
specifically authorized by
Statute New Hampshire has worked
extremely hard to ensure that students
with IEPs are receiving high quality
services starting with the referral
process diagnosis writing and monitoring
I APS all of which have parent and
family engagement if this bill were to
pass children youth and their families
would lose many aspects of the special
education process that they have come to
expect and deserve the New Hampshire
standards for students with disabilities
function as a guide for educators and
provide the much needed protections
afforded to New Hampshire's most complex
and vulnerable Children and Youth as we
drill down into the specifics of the
amendment it's filled with language that
is vague raises some questions and in
some instances is not in the best
interest of children and their families
and the educational communities that
serve them with the limited time I have
I'll will point out a few questions that
our members have brought forward for
your
consideration the amendment refers to
the uh special education Advocate as
having access to redacted records that
have personally identifiable student
data will this also include identifiable
data as it relates to family and and
School District staff fura defines State
educational authorities as having access
to Student Records is the New Hampshire
special education Advocate a state
educational Authority and has the office
of special education programs oep then
provided given guidance on this we
interpret uh State educational
authorities as the department of Ed um
we have many other questions that are
listed uh in our testimony for your
consider consideration and in summary
would ask um that you oppose this bill
and take the time for more deliberate um
information coming forward in the full
report J is the administrators
Association that you represent opposed
to the original 340 or this amendment to
the amendment thank you further
questions from representative pno thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question
um there's a lot of vague generalities
about um specific services and rights
that might be eliminated if this
amendment were to pass can you give me
one specific example please sure the
right now there are are several
different areas in which we exceed
Federal rules um we require additional
um parental consents our ref referral
process goes above and beyond what the
federal government requires when it
comes to evaluating kids we have um lure
requir ments that are above and beyond
Federal requirements um our IEP uh team
composition um components of the IEP so
we in a variety of areas I could go on
um but those are some examples that
really do impact
kids further questions representative uh
dry thank you thank you for taking my
question uh the previous um person Mr
Bell talked about sections of this that
would actually help in addressing the
concerns brought up in this large audit
and I feel like if we don't address
those we'll be kicking the can down the
road do would you agree with some of the
things in here that would help to
address this specifically right now I
think there's always room for
improvement in any system um and we're
happy to work with other stakeholders to
bring forward more um appropriate and
efficient processes um like I said we
value the audit um when you do some
self-reflection that's always an
important thing and there's always room
for
improvement um and and so yes thank you
represent whitcock then represent
leus thank you for taking my question
I'll only keep one um this bill that was
promulgated by the doe and brought forth
by represent cordelli uh in item five
seven talks about the minimum standards
uh now federal state his belief was that
nothing would happen to student services
right now is that your belief as well
that's not the way we interpreted it I
mean like this came at us pretty quickly
um and so our members um did not
interpret it that way thank you thank
you Mr chair represent leus yes thank
you thank you for taking my question a
previous speaker had said that they felt
that all of the roles that are there do
in fact follow uh are in fact authorized
by Statute I'm just wondering if you
would if you are a the same opinion that
they are currently authorized by Statute
to my knowledge yes thank
you further questions from the committee
thank you very much you're welcome like
to invite Caitlyn
Bernier hi my name is Caitlyn Bernier I
am here um I live in marac New Hampshire
and I'm here as a parent of a child in
the special ed um and I I just wanted to
point out um a couple things that uh New
Hampshire does that um the idea does not
include so New Hampshire rules prohibit
the use of um adversive including the
use of noxus myths denying a child food
drink or contact with parents electrical
stimul ation and unnecessary restraint
none of these are prohibited by the idea
and at least one school in a neighboring
state has routinely used electrical
shock to attempt to control kids um so
that's not that's one one thing there um
New Hampshire also requires uh parents
consent at each step in the special ed
process um and this includes transition
planning Beginning by age 14 instead of
16 which is the age that the idea
requires um and so um
sb340 would undo Decades of work by
families Advocates and Educators in many
areas New Hampshire just clarifies the
idea when we do more it doesn't mean
more costly or more cumbersome in most
case it just means more clear more
supportive of parent and school
Partnerships and more likely to maintain
the Integrity of the special ed process
um this amendment would hurt our
children and our families and the
Partnerships that we have with those
schools and those families and how that
reflects New Hampshire that's all are
there questions yes representative pel
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here and for taking my question
I'm confused does this bill say anywhere
or this amendment say anywhere that um
state law cannot exceed federal law so
where it says that provided that in no
case shall the State Board adopt a rule
that exceeds the state or federal
minimum requires unless the rule is um
specifically authorized by Statute that
was the part that we were talking about
on page three I think that's what it
is thank you I um I would read this as
saying um shall not ad shall adopt wait
no case in no case shall the State Board
adopt rle that exceed state or federal
minimum do you think that the or in
there would allow for exceeding federal
statute in New Hampshire statute yeah I
think that um the wording needs to be
more clear and concise uh so that people
aren't um uh perceiving it in different
ways so we don't go down this path any
further I want to advise the
committee our statutes do state that you
can go beyond federal and state in
regard to special there's no need to ask
any more questions that that's in
statute and it's for all areas of
special
education so no need to travel that road
any further we know that um from the
committee uh who is next with a hand up
here that's good thank you very much
thank you Michaela deer is Michaela
still here she had to be out here by 10
I'll text okay we'll let her come up
right after that David
Trumble see we
that good morning how's we today that's
good thank you Mr chairman my name is
David Trumble I'm from the town of wear
and I oppose this bill specifically the
part about the regulations and how they
relate to statutes the Department of
Education released a document it's 17
Pages it's called new standards in
excess chart I urge you all to just
Google it and find it it gives you an
idea of the types of things that they
want to get rid of in 2025 when they
rewrite the rules I'm going to walk
through a couple different legal
analysises first is that the statute
proposed says unless specifically
authorized but statutes right General
policy regulations do go into the
specific details for instance federal
law says you have to have Specialists
who are trained to work in the special
education field on this list the 17-page
list there's three different places they
want to write the Specialists out of the
rules another example that's a problem
with this proposal here is it only says
authorized by Statute the federal
government has a long list of federal
regulations in the cfrs that talk about
how special ed rules will be implemented
those rules have the effect of law if
you don't include that in this statute
you're basically saying if the federal
government went through the work of
telling you exactly what the details are
we don't have to do those in New
Hampshire because it's not mentioned in
federal statute why would the federal
government go through all those details
in the statute they set out the broad
General guidelines for example they say
parents have to be given notice on time
so they can participate the regulations
break it down this this bill here says
unless the federal law gave all those
details the number of days out it would
go this should be a this should be it
disregarded completely but the fact it
doesn't consider the Federal Regulations
as another legal deficiency third is the
word or in this list the 17-page list
they have categorical Aid because the
state requires categor catastrophic Aid
I'm sorry uh the federal government does
not so they want to get rid of
catastrophic Aid because it's not
required it says not not specifically
authorized by federal or state minimum
standards so if it's not in the FED
standards they're willing to get rid of
catastrophic Aid even though State
Statute requires it the types of people
who will be hurt by this bill medically
fragile children children who are two
and a half who hope to have a smooth and
effective transition when they start
getting services at the age of three
parents right to be informed on time the
role of Specialists including parent
professionals who are mentioned in the
federal regs the documentation of
services that goes on repeatedly that's
how parents know that their children are
getting those Services they need there's
numerous examples but those are three I
was say constitutional deficiencies in
this that statutes give General
regulations give details they don't
consider the code of federal regulations
and this word or means that even if
State Statute requires it if the federal
government does they can write it out of
our rules thank you Bo right on the
money any questions for
David yes represent Woodcock first thank
you for being here um the document that
you quoted uh
yes can you repeat that my low text
missed it okay great it's called New
Hampshire standards in excess chart I
just Googled it last night it's 17 pages
and it walks through everything that the
department of Ed thinks is in excess
which tells me this is what they want to
get rid of next year
just is that out of the doe website yes
right on the doe website well it's it's
it's a a Google address but it's a doe
document so we have copies here so thank
represent belshire thank you thank you
Mr chair and thank you for being here to
offer your testimony I
have I have a little bit of concern with
a couple things but there's one thing
you said that I I don't fully understand
I want to get into maybe I
misunderstood um you suggested I think
that this legislation or rather this
amendment would result in the um the
repeal or elimination of catastrophic
Aid despite it already being in New
statute and I don't really understand
that okay uh thank you for the question
representative belter my reading of this
law says that provided that in no case
the State Board of Education adopt a
rule that exceeds state or federal
minimum requirements unless the rule is
specifically authorized by Statute in
this chart it has one column for state
minimum requirement and one column for
federal minimum requirement in the chart
it mentions catastrophic Aid because it
says it catastrophic G is required by
State Statute but not by federal statute
so therefore it's on its list of things
that could be eliminated in 2025 because
it's it's uh a rule that would exceed
state or federal minimum standards so
other it would comply catastrophic a
complies with State Standards but it
would exceed federal minimum standards
and therefore they could get rid of it
under this law as
drafted just to clarify in statute right
now special education a which is what
cat Aid is is identified clearly in
statute the formula is in statute so
what the department of education does or
not does not want is not going to exceed
what we have in statute right now
they're not going to be able to say well
we're turning off cat a that is by
Statute and Mary you're on that
committee as well Mr chairman I think
that's great to hear you say that and
that gives us reassurance but it's on
the Doe's list of things that it wants
to get rid
of
okay we're the legislature and um I
appreciate where you're presenting to us
David but I I think you're safe on that
one okay thank you Mr are there further
questions just represent
leus can you um show me where in this
excess chart it says that they want to
get rid of these things I it doesn't say
that okay think it's it's a list of
standards that in their opinion are in
excess and under the way this statute is
proposed being written these could be
written out of the state of New
Hampshire's special ed regs if you pass
this law as it's written everything on
this list could be written out of the RS
I I'm not saying that they've said we
want to do it but if you compile a list
like this there's got to be a reason why
you did that other than for information
for us could just be information right
so but it's it's a concern to me and
other other people as well representa
Heath do you want to say something no
you're good with that okay
further you biting your tongue thank you
very much thank you Mr chairman uh i'
like to invite Moira Moira
Ryan good morning good morning my name
is Mora Ryan and I'm a parent and an
advocate for special education student
um I wanted to indicate here that New
Hampshire doe doesn't do anything with
the data they have they're not proactive
they're not looking for Trends and
they're not searching for things that
are not going well which is in part what
the audit had said um almost 20% of any
class of students are on IEPs less than
3% of those are so disabled that they
would not be able to function in society
um however less than 4% of those
children will have any postsecondary
opportunity in either College your
career um I don't want my kid independ I
don't want my kid dependent on the state
I want him to have a career my kid is on
an I um and at some point I want to
retire and I don't want to pay for a 20%
class of people who can't work or can't
function
um I went through every form of
alternative dispute resolution and even
when I won and was awarded Services
those Services were never happening you
can nitpick all these procedural
elements but if you're not getting
results it doesn't matter there was was
a famous story in the Army where there
were P planes built that weren't
wouldn't work for the pilots because
they only Built the planes to
accommodate 5'9 inch Pilots well Pilots
are all shapes and sizes and the problem
is that if we don't look at the outcomes
which are the most important thing and
we worry about whether or not so many
days is better then we're not focusing
on what's happening right now students
on disability students with iups don't
have rights because in some cases the
state restricts what they should have
and to give you an example of that the
age 22 bill which was passed this last
year the federal government said that
kids were supposed to be in school
through age 22 inclusive but that was
not happening in our state those kids
were getting kicked out on their 21st
birthday so they don't have rights they
don't even have this the floor of Ida
because that's not being followed so
unless we start looking at the outcomes
and start trying to fix the issues which
was the purpose of the audit we're not
going to get anywhere I mean we didn't
look at the leas which is where most of
these problems are
happening
um another example would be that there's
a state regulation that says that um an
outof District placement school has to
be a state approved school well if I
have a kid who has dyslexia who needs
Orton Gillingham and needs to go to
Linda moodbell or an academy like that
that's not a state approved school and
that's not in the federal rules and that
kid is not getting the services that
they
need the fact that New Hampshire doe
when they were asked to come before this
committee for the audit said that they
didn't want to do enforcement which in
incidentally they're getting paid $58
million a year from the federal doe to
do uh because it would be a liability to
them should be a great concern and there
should be a lot more legislation to
protect these kids because they're not
getting the bare minimum right now and
their outcomes are poor this 4% of
postsecondary that's the federal ours is
probably lower and I have to say us news
and World Report just came out with
their report on school districts
and londondary was 18 out of 100 for
College and Career Readiness which is a
high socioeconomic district and should
be at the top of the list thank you
other questions from Miss
Ryan thank you very
much is Michaela back here did she come
back the
meter no guess not okay uh Karen uh
Blake
black Bale b l
a
okay
okay is that L okay at the
end okay okay thank
[Music]
you good morning welcome good morning
chairman lad and members of the
education uh House Education committee
I'm here uh my name is Karen Blake and I
live in North Woodstock New Hampshire in
full disclosure I am also the director
of Community Partnerships for Community
Crossroads I am also the current chair
of the family support advisory Council
for Northern Human Services however
today I am testifying only on behalf of
myself and my
family um I am here today in opposition
to the non- gerain amendment for Senate
Bill
340 um I'm going to spend my my 3
minutes talking about my family and how
the current regulations over and above
the federal minimum standards for Ida
have benefited
us um I do want to talk a little bit
about uh my son he is given special
permission for me to discuss him today
he is now 17 years old and this is his
life not mine however this was too
important to not talk in specifics he
did ask that I just not mention his name
or any pictures there were going to be
pictures okay so with the current
Amendment um if it was enacted when my
son entered school at 3 transitioning
from early supports and services to the
school district that possibly could have
been the last time that me and my late
husband would have signed sign off on
his
IEP think about that my son is now 17
years old and we have had a rocky road
at different points but because I and my
late husband were an integral part of
his IEP team he is now posed to graduate
on time with a high school diploma and
he is posed to go to college we have
been on college tours that is something
that when my son was 3 years old and
couldn't speak we stay mon we couldn't
have even
imagined and I do want to say that
because we were part of the process at
every single step we work together as a
team we still work together as a team my
son um had a very very Rocky start to
his educational career if you will there
were there were days that I was getting
called every single day by the school
there were times where he was being
restrained in school multiple times a
month and we worked through it we worked
together and at in the third grade there
was a very strong possibility that we
were looking at an out of District
placement now imagine Lincoln Woodstock
my little school district in the north
having to pay an outof District
placement for all of the these years and
more importantly what would it have done
to my son so just very very quickly I do
want to just throw one out a couple of
things out there that that
three-year-old who couldn't speak
actually just won second place in the
Poetry out loud because of everything
that we did thank you all very much and
uh my written testimony goes into a lot
more detail congratulations on the
winning uh represent Heath just I don't
have to cry here um
congratulations um do you believe that
because you worked in partnership with
the school district you went hand inand
together with them that you came up with
the best solutions for your son
absolutely thank you welcome further
questions from the
committee thank you very much thank you
all uh Moren PE
my name is Marin PRL I'm from New London
New Hampshire and I am a retired speech
language pathologist working in the kir
school district um I cannot improve on
all of the testimony that has come
before me so I'm not going to take up
any of your time I just want to say to
quote um Senator cordelli that we're not
really sure if these are less
restrictive or more restrictive rules
that we're looking at we need to do a
deeper dive and I would suggest to you
given all the testimony that has come
before us that that's exactly what you
need to do you need to take a deeper
dive you need to take a deep breath and
vote this amendment down and really
explore it with a well thought out
team and come back with more knowledge
about what it is I would encourage you
not to throw the baby out with the bath
water which is what I think this
amendment would do thank you thank you
very
much no question okay uh would like to
Lauren DWI
morning Lauren
hi you lower this a little
bit thank you chairman lad and education
committee House Education committee for
having us here today um I didn't have a
lot of time to prepare this I just found
out about this yesterday and missing
work today to be here so I appreciate
you hearing me um so my name is Lauren
DWI I live in pemrick New Hampshire with
my husband and daughter I am here today
to oppose the non-main amendment to
sb340 my daughter has benefited from a
robust IEP individualized education plan
I'm learning not to speak in acronyms
it's really
hard um and put in place by her team as
the parent I am a valued member of this
team and able to not only provide the
helpful information only a parent can
but also have the ability to fully
consent or partially consent to what is
in the plan I am always able to come to
IEP meetings prepared because I am
provided with copies of all recent evals
and assessments 5 days before the
meeting which gives me time to go
through this wealth of information
it's a lot it's
intimidating um I know how she was doing
because I know how the IEP is
implemented and the skill set she is
mastering as a parent an advocate this
transparency and accountability is
Paramount there is nothing on this Earth
more important to me than my daughter
and ensuring a positive future for her
adopting this amendment makes my job
harder and puts my child at risk
as it strips away protections from the
use of aversives and transparent
communication with families like mine I
implore you to oppose this amendment and
send a clear message that New Hampshire
cares for and values all
children thank you thank you very much
Lauren you get the penmanship award on
your card it's
perfect do you need a note for your work
from
us okay are there any questions
represent leus then representative
Cornell okay thank you for answering my
question I'm confused and I'm trying to
find on
here um what part would strip
away all those wonderful things you were
talking about there is a risk if I'm
reading everything correctly and what
people in the back have also been
testifying too is if I
can't if I don't have access to the team
the way I always have had access to my
team all of her information certain
protections that go over and Beyond I so
you're talking about the um that one
under Roman numeral 8 that part most
likely yes okay again this was very
short notice um it's fine I was just
trying to figure out what part of this
would cause you problems thank
you represent Cornell Thank you thank
you for taking my question so with this
non derain Amendment you feel like that
you would be losing some of your
parental rights as regards your child's
special education yes I do yes I do
thank you are there further questions
from the committee thank you very much
thank you on on another note I I would
like to encourage you to listen to all
of us as we are the experts in what our
lives are like and this is an experience
that we live every day with
Communications that we have constantly
with our schools and the amazing
Educators in our state and we value the
testimony of our public very much so
thank you thank you uh uh Micha are you
back in the room
now Michaela deer yes okay good morning
everyone thank you for waiting the
Beauty and the drawback of working in
conquered is that I get to do all kinds
of things today good morning everyone um
chairman lab members of the House
Education committee my name is Michaela
Deiter and today I come before you as
the mom of a student who receives
special education services in Dober
Public Schools today I speak only for
myself but more importantly today I'm
here to represent the best interests of
my 14-year-old son an eighth grader at
Dober Middle School who has been
receiving special education services for
the past six years to support his
diagnoses of autism anxiety OCD and
ADHD I'm here in opposition to the
Amendment put forward a week ago SP 340
began as an exceedingly straightforward
proposal allowing special education
documents to be shared with families via
email indeed the Bill's language was a
single sentence with 37 words in total I
counted in its proposed amended format
section five strips away currently held
protections for special education
students Educators and families by
limiting special education rules to
nothing more than the minimum Allowed by
state or feder eneral law as a parent I
reject the suggestion that a bare
minimum is sufficient for my son and the
other almost 31,000 special education
students in New Hampshire current rules
offer protections for students regarding
communication parental consent restraint
transition planning IEP implementation
reporting and many other rights many of
these important protections will
evaporate under the anemic standards of
state and federal minimums many me
members of this committee have spoken
publicly in support of parental rights
and parental notifications I urge you to
consider how section five of this
proposed amendment would take away the
rights of parents and Guardians to make
timely informed decisions for their
children who require special education
services my son's annual IEP meeting
happened a few weeks ago and my husband
and I received the proposed IEP document
a week in advance which was a good thing
because it is 24 pages single spaced
without the communication timeline
protections offered in current law I
might not have received that document in
advance of our meeting which would have
made it impossible for me to arrive
prepared to discuss the proposal with
his treatment team recent history has
shown us just how hard the disability
Community has had to work to carve out
educational rights for themselves in the
first place I urge the committee to vote
no on this amendment and return to the
language as originally written this
amendment is a move in the wrong
direction ction New Hampshire special
educations deserve far more than the
bare minimum thank you thank you very
much are there questions yes represent
dry thank you and thank you for coming
for and thank you for your testimony um
I I understand that if this that one
section were included here you feel like
it would destroy a lot of good things
that are working for you um this report
talks about things that are not working
for a lot of people in due process does
the rest of the amendment which
addresses those problems um is that past
your muster that's a great question I
had thought about that I I with 3
minutes I didn't have time to address
everything um but thank you for the
question I don't have a strong opinion
one way or the other I have read this
proposed amendment several times I think
there are some merits to many of the
things that representative cordelli had
talked about earlier but before I had to
step out for my meeting um I apologize I
missed probably a lot of the robust
discussion that has already happened um
I the one thing that gave me pause was
wondering whether it would be um an
undue burden on the office of the
special education Advocate to have to
enter into specific memorandums of
understanding for each investigative
case um I because I sit on the school
board in my city we we enter into
memorandums of understanding and my
experience is that they can be a little
burdensome and cumbersome and um I I
want to make sure that the good work
that that um that office and that role
is doing is not unduly burdened by um
paperwork and um and things that would
create more of a hassle in understanding
the situation getting the material that
is needed to be able to do that
investigative work so all that to say I
don't have a strong opinion on a lot of
the other things um I I think there is
probably at least some Merit to much of
of what else is in there which is why my
testimony Focus specifically on Section
Five thanks thank you very much further
questions thank you thank you uh
representative Tim Horgan
thank you very much I'm president
Timothy Oran straford County's district
10 the towns of just the town of Durham
and I guess I'm the first and probably
only uh legislator to come in and way on
this amendment and like uh probably
pretty much everyone else who spoke
except for cordelli I'm uh I'm uh I'm
opposed to it um
and I I do do understand you know you
are going to be apparently excting it
today and perhaps you know perhaps
something acceptable will come out of uh
will come out of the executive process
right now I anticipate you know not
being able to concur with the amendment
and my major major
objection is of course is Section
Five and
um as I agree with others that's totally
unacceptable like using the existing
statutes as a floor they were supposed
to be a you know that was not or a
ceiling there's supposed to be a floor
there's supposed to be a minimum so I
think anything that causes less special
education services is not good I
sponsored as you remember HB 1665 which
passed this house by a uh bipartisan
super majority but it looks like the
other body on the other side of the wall
which shall not be named is apparently
going to set up the interim study which
in their case doesn't mean there's
likely to be any study so but um so this
does cut back special ed services and
need if you take that section out I'm
wondering what else you what else is
hidden in there that's not good I mean
some of it's good but I'm wondering
there's probably other things that are
bad certainly one specific thing that
jumps out at me is um if this passes
it'll be take effect 60 days after we
the governor signs it so that's uh in J
that's like in August sometime or July
and um the uh there's a report that's
going to be generated by September 1st
so that gives an unreasonably low amount
of time for the office of the special
Advocate who produce that report and
sounds like there's some organization
issue with the office of special
advocate in fact I think I heard that
there's only one person in the office
and I try to look up the website well
it's multitasking waiting and you know
they have an organization chart which
supposed we have about a dozen people in
it so there's a discrepancy there that
um and um
and also something that's emic to all a
lot of education laws is this is only
about the school districts um as you
know that's the biggest part of publicly
funded education but there's also uh
public charter schools there's also the
public
academies there's also the uh EFA school
program that's either the education
Freedom account or School voucher
depending in which side of the issue
you're on um either way there's the
children's scholarship organization
um which has to deal with special
education issues there's the various
providers that are subsidized by that
program they have special education
issues involved too so that's and that's
more of a problem with the whole RSA
186c that it needs to be updated so I I
just uh I certainly I certainly will
keep a somewhat open mind depending on
what you decide which I guess is today
but I really just anticipate to this
amendment will not be acceptable to me
personally and um I certainly the
simplest thing to do this lad session is
just passed the original Bill thanks are
there any questions for the
representative not seeing thank you I'll
just add that section five it seems very
clear to me that it I think it means
what it says and I you're some people we
got it got it Tim thanks uh Carrie
Duran car here
good morning my name is Carrie Duran I'm
from wolfboro I'm here with my daughter
Katie she's in green she's 13 years old
she attends Kingswood middle school and
we are here today to strongly oppose the
amendment thank you um chairman lad of
members of the committee for giving me
the opportunity to speak today um I just
wanted to reiterate what everyone all
the parent Advocates especially have
said that the communication and being
part of the team is so important I'm a
single parent to be able to have
notifications
uh in advance to be able to have um the
parent consent all of the documents this
year has been um quite a busy year for
Katie we added two new diagnosis for her
and she was diagnosed with Down syndrome
when she was born and she just was
recently diagnosed with hearing loss and
we also implemented a behavioral plan
with her for her as well um that was a
result of her um communication issues
with her hearing loss if I wasn't able
to have the opportunity to speak
directly with our team anytime I needed
to get that documentation ask for
further evaluations for her so she could
be successful I would not have a kiddo
that sits behind you that has
aspirations to go to UNH for the UNH for
you program we just recently went to
college tours for her big sisters who
graduate this year and when we went for
those college tours she was the one
asking where's my program I'm going to
be going to college here my name is
Katie and just walking up and and she
knows that she wants to be ready to go
to college and have those opportunities
and that is because of the amazing team
that we have in our school district and
it is because of the amazing um services
that we go above and beyond in the state
of New Hampshire to provide that my
daughter is going to have the
opportunity to go to college the
opportunity to work live on her own be
independent that's what we've worked so
hard to do and in the state of New
Hampshire we have so many as you can see
behind me amazing parent and educator
Advocates I would uh implore you to
consider taking a pause on this
amendment bringing forth some of those
stakeholders and parents and really
hearing from them and as somebody else
mentioned getting into that Manu
with the parents at the table to share
with you how important every step of
this process is I rely on it I need that
partner with my school district I cannot
do it by myself to ensure Katie has
everything she needs and I'm so grateful
for every service that she's been
provided the care of her teachers and
her team and I implore you again to vote
no on this amendment thank you so much
thank you very
much oh right on time yeah it was good
timing are are there any questions from
the yes representative pel thank you and
thank you for being here and um if I
don't catch Katie make sure I said hello
to her
she representative penell and
representative cordelli are my
Representatives so we know each other
I'm just confused about um the
communication that will change by
passing this amendment because of course
we want parents to work hand
inand with the school district when it
comes to their children so where exactly
are your concerns coming from in this
amendment my concerns are primarily with
the section five that have been
mentioned it is my understanding that we
are opening the door to be able to take
away those protections that we do have
where we do go above and beyond what the
federal government standards are that's
my understanding but it's been difficult
because I just found out about this on
Sunday and you know trying to review and
working and the kids and you know I'm
just happy to be here and I brought my
kid along and but um yeah we needed a
little more time to to review also thank
you I have no idea what you're talking
about not having time I know I know
thank you very much are there further
questions thank you very much thank
daughter too thank you you're welcome
i' like to invite Robert
bevel Robert here oh that's you might
have two of them okay um then I'd like
to go down to uh looks like Karen
Hughes thank you very
much uh Joanne
gocker good morning almost good
afternoon my name is Joanne grer I live
in marac with my two daughters who
attend public school and have IEPs I
oppose the bill as amended the amendment
removes the protections provided to
parents and students with disabilities
as part of the special education process
in New Hampshire the amendment will not
require parents to provide informed
consent every time an IEP is proposed
the timelines in law just say reasonable
so New Hampshire specif hi specific days
reverting to this vague language puts
parents at a disadvantage in an already
confusing system the timelines that will
be removed are ones that state parents
must be given notice before an IEP team
meeting 10 days in advance 5 days for a
manifestation determination meeting for
Behavior parents must be given 14 days
to respond by giving or denying consent
or providing partial consent to a school
district's proposal a school district
must respond to a parents request for an
IEP meeting in 21 days and also removes
that New Hampshire as a timeline of 60
calendar days for initial evaluations
and re-evaluations can be an additional
30 if you remove all these timelines it
creates unnecessary delays and confusion
for families if you remove the
protection of parents providing informed
consent you're creating an imbalance of
power and sending the message that
parents are not an equal team member of
the IEP team and this moves what should
be an IEP team conversation
automatically to dispute resolution if
you don't allow parents to agree
partially agree or disagree with an IEP
if you automatically implement the IEP
and force parents into dispute
resolution it's no longer a team process
it becomes really contentious so I
oppose this bill with the amendment that
removes rights for families thank you
very much other questions from the
committee
not see you thank you very much like to
invite Kristen man
Manon and I always have a hard time with
that
Kristen uh office of special education
Advocate good morning Kristen monani
Office of the advocate for special
education it is the child's Advocate
that has about 12 staff ours does have
only one right now um I was prepared I I
worked closely on all of this language
except the language that has spent our
whole morning with doe um and I think
both of us would have been prepared kind
of at 9:30 to say strip out four lines
of this section five there have been
good questions about it representative
leas representative peternell about you
know does it really minimize rights
wasn't it forward-looking but we were
fully prepared in order to focus on the
language we did actually work on to say
eliminate that so to come to the
language we did work on which is the
rest of it and I'm hoping you all will
ask me questions about that um it was
designed to get at representative
Heath's point and and all of the parent
testimony we need more oversight more
ways to make sure that parents and
districts are working
together this was supposed to be very
timely a quick response to the audit on
dispute resolution Which is less than 5%
of the 95% of special education it does
need attention because dispute
resolution is precisely where the
hand-in-hand partnership has broken down
between parents and
districts um to representative Luna's
Point um much earlier on with
questioning uh the language that we did
work on everything except those lines of
section five was really intended
precisely um and the Department of
Education was very willing to take on
more managerial oversight and all of
these Provisions actually do put burden
on them and they give office access to
sort of look at turning anecdote into
Data um a lot of the special education
audit report did rely on some parental
anecdote you know the stories of what
has gone wrong for them in doing dispute
resolution one of the auditor main
concerns was we went to the doe and we
said give us charts and data of
timelines you know for how these
procedures have been overseen
um and it was in staff heads again
anecdote and not as clearly in data so
so the intent of all of the other
language in here was to turn anecdote
into data and then give in the future
potentially the legislature much more
concrete information my office more
concrete information even doe itself um
the ability to say okay is more Staffing
needed what is the scope of the problem
in terms of all of these anecdotal
stories of struggles with dispute
solution many of the things you've heard
about are going to be the other audit
95% of special EDS so I would ask very
strongly for questions on everything but
that language and that instead of voting
against this full amendment that um all
of the legislators say let's consider
all of the language except those four
lines and take them
out thank you thank you very much um I
do have a question for you um having
having worked with you a bit on this
um and taking section five and putting
that over here do you have a problem or
is there I recognize we have a database
problem at the department with
software that's unable to deliver an
individual report to you you end up
seeing everything there is theou partial
resolve to this or or you know where if
we get anou between your department you
and the
doe a where they would provide that
individual report to you is that going
to give you all the information that you
need or are you looking for more
aggregate information of of of processes
and looking at how many were there in
this particular year or the preceding
year that were due process and is that
where you're going to get the
information or you're going to get it at
the local
level a lot of questions in there there
are a lot of questions in there I'm
going to try to do them all quickly yeah
um theou was not my first preference in
this as as representative cordelli said
this went through many drafts I am
comfortable with theou um there were a
lot of concerns raised about privacy I
was asking for full access to our nessus
database um I believe that was initially
um kind of part of the intent of access
which is not in this amendment but
separate um in legislation I am okay
with the I think it will get me um and
my off it's a lot of the information
that we're seeking I've worked closely
with my colleagues At Doe um and I think
what we can do you know they've really
taken on burden in this so I I think I
want to say at no point was doe trying
to put any language in that allowed them
to get rid of all of the um rules in
excess that that was never any part of
any discussion here so I really feel
like they've been a bit vilified there
they were taking on burden to themselves
they were conscious of not overburdening
our districts um and there was a lot of
discussion about burden on privacy and
confidentiality if we went with my
office having full access as opposed to
anou that got reports from the
Department that they would be taking on
the burden of preparing and so we
settled on theou and the report piece um
I think it will go a long way um and I'm
comfortable with it as a first step
that's very responsive to the audit and
lets us really look at what's needed
here to ensure that our special
education dollars which are substantial
are really about parent and um School
District
Partnerships and that we're not spending
dollars for services that aren't agreed
where things have really broken down um
so in terms of the local piece that has
been brought up a couple times
representative Woodcock I think you
mentioned at the local District piece
where documents are
alleged um this this did get a lot of
attention um from the Department staff
and myself and you know a it was settled
on that
we were not putting a burden on local
districts to come up with anything new
we were simply saying if you have
dispute resolution processes that will
be less easy in all of the other
language of this legislation which deals
with reports I could get through
Theseus if local districts have those
separate resolution processes tell the
department what they are and to
representative woodcock's point the
sentence goes on to say that local
districts will um report on which have
been used within in the district each
year including the topic of the dispute
and the resolution if any and there our
vision was that there would be timelines
there as well that was a big part of the
audit is give us reports that show
us you know disputes resolutions and the
timelines of those and we have to
disaggregate some happen at the local
level a fraction happen at the state
level I'd like to see a little bit more
but I think it's all well
addressed thank you represent beler
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here for your uh for your
testimony and this question which deals
with not the one that's been
particularly controversial so far but
kind of what we were just discussing on
page two um lines 10 through
14 um shows a number of category of
Parental refusals on and on to uh to
tracking those refusals and um whatnot
and my concern here would be does this
not perhaps provide a a further impetus
or incentive or disincentive necess how
you look at it
to have
schools um initiate dispute resolution
processes when parents are refusing
Services um absolutely I I don't think
it provides a disincentive I actually
think it provides an incentive um right
now very few school districts are the
ones who initiate those dispute resol
solution
processes um they have more resources to
do it they have kind of attorneys that
they can hire to get that done quickly
for parents it is much harder to
initiate a dispute resolution process
but as a result sometimes IEPs sit
forever with parental refusal we're at
an impass and money is being spended on
services to students that either are
from years prior IEPs not matching where
the student is at that point
or that parents disagree with saying you
know you're you're spending this money
on this service for my student I don't
think he or she needs that he or she
needs this so um it is an
incentive I think um districts would not
be penalized by this because the report
would show they filed they got a dispute
resol quickly right instead of having an
IEP sit unconsented for two
years H be careful just very very
briefly and thank you for speak because
that's exactly what I was interested I'm
just wondering is there not a cause for
us to have concern for schools having an
new incentive to initiate dispute
resolution against parents who may not
want certain
services so my answer is outside the
scope of this but um definitely going to
be advocating for more staff for my
office and one of the things that the
department is taking on and as I said
they have actually taken on a lot of
responsibility in all of this strip
section five out with which they had no
comment on and never tried to initiate
um the we've all admitted there would be
more resources needed but one of the
things the department has taken on um
and it is explicitly laid out in here is
that they would be running reports
currently they have access to the data
there's no burden on the districts um
they are required whether or not they
use nessus our database to create their
IEPs or their notices they are required
to report in there with a couple clicks
of a button whether parents have refused
an
IEP and the
date currently doe doesn't and in part
it will require some staff adjustment on
their part run reports on that data they
have fully committed to and and and
really quickly saying we can run monthly
reports on that data my office would
probably be requesting those reports and
we will take the initiative monthly to
send to every parent who showed up as
refusing consent a one-page clear
statement we understand you just refused
consent here are your resources that
would include the listing of my office
right now I don't have staff to even
begin to take care of that but that's a
separate piece that we'll address um the
doe does not have enough staff in terms
of hearing officers again we want to
turn anecdotes into Data so that the
legislature can see what you know it
might address in the future um via this
limited legislation so I don't think
parents would be harmed as long as we
can get them some resources um um to put
their points out there and honestly with
those dispute resolution processes I've
seen some of them turn out um especially
recently in parent in Parental favor and
that would certainly be my objective if
I thought it warranted thank you further
questions represented Ry thank you and
thank you for taking my question um I'm
glad that you are comfortable with the
idea of anou are you comfortable with
the idea of maintaining multiple M us at
the same
time so um this legislation I do not
read as requiring me to have anou for
access to every single individual file
um what it will do you know for there is
a question or a debate but it would be
solved outside of anou um and I we would
go with whatever a school district
requested so as not to waste time on the
battle but parents who come to my office
and ask for my help and that of Staff
whom I hope to have
uh can easily sign consent for us to
have access to anything and arguable
legislation creating my office already
created that right even without parental
consent so none of those accessing of
documents would require anou theou would
be more for me to get the monthly
reports and the annual data that is
contemplated in this legislation from
doe represent
Woodcock good morning um just a question
you indicated that you were part of the
group that developed the first four and
talk about the first four can you tell
me where the fifth one came from um
there was believe it or not there were
parents involved in this um who you know
and and representative cordelli was
acting on some of that parental feedback
at the time um and several pieces that I
think he cited in the legislative audit
that said look we're layering on and I
have given testimony as to this too
we're layering on additional pieces
again we can understand how five came
about better if we understand that this
was meant to be solely about dispute
resolution in response to the audit so
there are a number of areas in the
dispute resolution piece that were cited
as having been kind of excess processes
that created confusion excess
requirements um so initially this came
about and and obviously didn't have
enough Focus which is why I said
perfectly happy to recommend we delete
that and go with the rest um it came
about in response to let's not create
excess that elongates processes creates
confusion puts parents through uh where
do I go someone said here someone said
here someone said here all of those
being potentially true let's get things
a little bit more streamlined and clear
that was the Genesis of it um and it was
kind of some meetings with parents and
some
feedback I think it needs more thank
study uh I do
have um are we also going to be hearing
from the Department yes we have some
technical advice but they're not taking
positions on things but technical
question we have several agencies that
want to provide technical support but I
have one more question for you um when
you're requesting from the Department
from that
database seems to be the real one of the
big issues we're dealing with here and
you're asking for a singular record I
understand that but when you're then at
looking for multiple records during the
course of the year maybe to give you a
profile on what is going on in terms of
the the number of going due process rout
for those that may not um we get into
possible litigation and liability issues
with the department and that it to me is
a real concern here where we're going to
be Loy Lo loing up people I'm getting
tired here but it's going to be a costly
issue did we address that or has that
been addressed by yourself or at least
through theou I think it's fully
addressed in the sense um as as you said
representative lad you did some work
with us on this there was language in
this bill that was much broader in terms
of my office's access to the database
itself um which has been stripped from
it so the mou I really think is looking
for um more aggregate data the one place
that someone pointed out it does mention
personally identifiable information is
in there um with respect
specifically to um disputes that go to
the state level and either get to due
process or get to um State complaint
pieces and the personally identifiable
information um was in there in order to
be able to say okay we have this report
where a 100 parents in the past 30 days
have refused their
IEPs I need a little bit of information
just to know which ones of those went by
student ID or something which of those
went where for resolution that was The
Limited kind of scenario of that piece
but I think the broader issues you're
referring to that there were concerns
from doj about um liability and about
confidentiality I think that's been
stripped from this there is no nothing
that gives my office um that the
provisions they were most concerned
about were deleted in their entirety
okay I was thinking dog thank you um
further questions representa
leus thank you um
I just want to make sure I understand
what you said about uh section five
Roman numeral 8 that that was not
intended to be all of the rules
regarding special ed but only that
regarding
to uh dispute resolution is that did I
understand that correctly um to clarify
that someone asked me how uh
representative Woodcock I believe asked
me how that got in there um um it got in
there in a discussion about rules
relating to dis dispute resolution um
the way it is written and that is why I
would support it it's
broader thank Youk thank you very much
further questions thank you very much
thank you I'd like to call
um U Michelle wer
werin okay New Hampshire legal
assistance thank you I'm hble chair and
members of the committee so I am here to
testify in support of um I'm sorry I'm
Michelle Wen um from the New Hampshire
legal assistance I'm the youth Law
Project Director there who works with
children involved in special education
issues school to prison pipeline issues
and then also Foster youth um I'm here
to testify in support of sections 2
three and four which is what you just
heard of um in terms of data sharing
data is always good more data um is
always a good thing and I think we can
do lots of good things with that data as
demonstrated by the recent audit audit
however I'm taking no position on one in
six and I testifying in strong
opposition to section five as you've
heard from many people before me this
seems to be a very dangerous POS um
provision in terms of parental rights
one of the things that I don't think has
been discussed that I just wanted to
bring your attention to is that RSA 541
a17 says no rule and this is talking
about about the doe rules inclusive um
shall be effective for a period of
longer than 10 years except as extended
pursuant to other portions of 541a so
what that provision says is that all
rules including these doe rules have
will expire after 10 years and must be
reauthorized the way section five is
written the rules as they exist now
cannot be reauthorized to the extent
they exceed federal law um If This Were
to pass so with the with representative
leus your question is is this looking
retroactively or to the
Future it could potentially be to the
Future until we hit the reauthorization
time at which point all of the
protections that you've heard that these
families have benefited from would not
be able to be reauthorized so I think
that's a really important point and why
this um why this provision is dangerous
for these families who have benefited
from these protections for so long um I
have worked I work primarily with
lowincome folks um who are whose
children are struggling in the education
world and they struggle tremendously
just to get in the door of special
education um the the rules surrounding
their access to information the
timelines by which they must hear back
from the schools those are really
important for them and when I get
involved in cases they often have gone
years years without even getting a call
back from districts and so what I ask
you to do is I think the the the doe
audit is problematic it is incredibly
problematic but removing protections
that parents benefit from I don't think
is the way to address this I think the
way to address this um is to bolster the
doe oversight of local school districts
and ensure that they have the resources
to provide the oversight of local school
districts that they need um the office
of the special education Advocate is
helping it's helping bring to light some
of the problems in the local school
districts but again when you know when
I've represented parents and they file
complaints against districts I mean
we've I've been in litigation over yes
the school district has violated the
special education rules however we're
not going to provide you any relief I
actually brought that complaint to the
New Hampshire Supreme Court and we ended
up mediating and you know it is what it
is but
but that the problem is the oversight
not not the rules that we Empower
parents to be able to access their
rights and so I just I again I just want
to testify in strong opposition to
section five um and and and also just
the um I guess the sense that we may be
better off um having these rules and
statute as opposed to in rules my
concern there having been part of the
rul making process I'm just going to
finish this one thought um is that the
rul making process is done by Educators
doe stakeholders who are very intimately
involved in this work my worry taking it
out of the hands of that process and
into the legislature is is it becomes
very um subject to the whim of politics
at any time and education should be
stable for parents and the doe and
school districts so that they know what
to expect year after year and they know
that this 10-year reauthorization
process is coming up and they need to be
engaged and involved in that process to
make sure that children and school
districts and the budget are all
protected in a way that we want it to be
thank you you I'm sorry
represent thank you um my question since
we have established that all of the
rules that are
currently here are actually authorized
by
Statute is there any reason that when we
look at them again that they would go
away if we have already authorized them
by Statute statute doesn't go away so
why would the rules go or how would the
rules go away yep so so in section five
it says in no case shall the State Board
adopt a rule that exceeds state or
federal minimum requirements unless
unless the rule is specifically
authorized by Statute so Ru making is
authorized by by Statute so either and
one of two things could happen here
either section Section 5 is meaningless
because all rules are authorized by
Statute or it would be interpreted to
mean that the rules authorized by the
Department of Education and subject to
Jael car um could not exceed Federal
requirements so to the extent there's
that list of document or the list of
rules that exceed federal law those
rules could not be reauthorized if we
don't interpret it like that
this section has no impact and it's
superflous and why would we pass a
superus law thank you thank you very
much thank you thank
you oh was there oh yes representa
Howard oh so
apologies didn't see your hand yeah
sorry about that thank you Mr chairman
and thank you for taking my question uh
do you know when a majority of rules
will need to be Rewritten by so I
believe the last reauthorization was
2017 that's when I was involved in it
and that's I think what the rule book
says so I think it's
2027 okay um although I've heard 2025
here today I don't know where that's
coming from um so I would have said 2027
somebody may have more information than
I do I think that's a question for the
department so about one to three years
one to three years okay thank you and we
can find exactly because we have the
department here and they can Us in that
you you have a question da and just a
follow up on that so so would that
affect
um kids that have students that have
IEPs right now
potentially I think I
think would it tomorrow I mean I think
it depends on how how no no no I'm
talking about effect the students by the
time they get to you know when they're
in school in 2027 yes so we're talking
about you know K through nine if this is
not a superflous law and it means what
it says it means that the department
cannot um pass
rules that exceed federal or state law
um and there's not a state law
specifically
authorizing that protection I think it
it absolutely will have an impact and I
can give you an example so um rules so
so the doe is authorized to implement
rules pertaining to school discipline
and statute there there's always we we
readed the statute several years ago
but when the department implemented
rules pertaining to school discipline um
the Supreme Court in 2011 and enry
Keegan B had the opportunity to assess
whether or not um the rules pertaining
to school discipline which provides some
provided schools some guideposts of when
to implement what type of discipline um
the Supreme Court said that those rules
exceeded SE federal or exceeded State
Statute because the state statute was so
abroad and it it essentially said that a
school could impose any type of
discipline for any purpose the doe tried
to put some guideposts around that the
Supreme Court invalidated those rules
completely um because those guideposts
were not um were not auth were not
authorized by the specific statute and
so again with that lens taking away
these protections and explicitly saying
that the rules cannot exceed federal law
or state statute when we have a statute
that that does authorize this rulle
making is very dangerous and needs a lot
more thought if we don't want to harm
Children and
Families further
questions thank you very much thank you
uh Jennifer Earl
welcome thank you thank you chairman lad
and House Education committee my name is
Jennifer Belmont Earl I live in
barington with my husband and our two
schoolage children Sammy dude and ziki
Zoo um I'm opposed to the non- derain
amendment to
sb340 my children have individualized
educational programs and both are
protected by the New Hampshire standards
for the education for children with
disabilities if this non- derain
amendment is adopted these rules will be
at risk as we just heard um and my boys
could be at risk according to the
amendment administrative rules regarding
special education shall not exce exceed
state or federal minimum requirements
unless specific specifically authorized
by
Statute Um this can mean that the New
Hampshire standards for the education
for children with disabilities which do
exceed federal and state minimum
requirements could be done away with
possibly as early as next year we hear
that this leaves all children with an
IEP in a vulnerable and uncertain
position their families would not have
clear rules to follow when advocating
for their children's education and
safety the New Hampshire standards
protects our children from aversive
therapies and from from being placed in
an out ofate facility that uses
aversives aversives are a discredited
form of therapy that values compliance
above the well-being of the child
removing the standards possibly um
because they are not the minimum state
requirements can open the door to such
practices as shocking children with an
electric prod which is still used in the
judge rotenberg Center in
Massachusetts now because of the rules
our children cannot be played placed in
the judge rotenberg Center um but remove
them and it becomes an
option my family history taught me that
I can never take my children's safety
for granted my grandfather was one of
the people that were snuck into the
lonia state school in the 1950s to film
the abuses happening to disabled
children there in the hope that the New
Hampshire government would do something
about it it took
decades if you attach this gerain
amendment to SP 340 you could be opening
a door to abuses that could take decades
to end I sorry that I have to say these
things I am sorry I need to protect my
children from them but apparently I do
the risk this amendment poses to my
children who are in preschool in first
grade so if in three years this passes
they will still be in elementary school
that's real
and other children like
them your job is to make sure you learn
from our history and continue to protect
the work of generations of people
Generations that have made New Hampshire
a place that values all our
children and think we deserve more than
just minimum requirements and thank you
thank you very much other questions from
the
committee not seeing any thank you
okay uh Deborah house
then we got
Becky then we have uh some
technical good morning chairman L my
name good morning good morning yes it is
still morning my name is Deborah house
uh I am the President of the American
Federation of teachers New Hampshire and
I am here to speak in opposition of this
non- gerain amendment now we had no
problem with the original s SP 340 which
was a way to make communication a little
bit easier between parents and uh school
districts and schools um when uh
delivering notices about routine um
communication for students with
disabilities this however goes far
beyond that which is why it's an 100
Main Amendment but it comes up at the
last moment and certainly we did not
have time to do a lot of study on it but
our main concern is what you purpose
many others here it's about that section
five where uh we're talking about rule
um rule making that exceed state or
federal minimum requirements unless the
rule is specifically authorized by
Statute um every Grand State child has
the constitutional right to a robust
public education that's every single
granted State Child even those that have
special learning needs that need support
with special education services you've
heard from many um pass parents here
speaking up for their children all of
those students have the right to access
a free and appropriate public education
and those are supported by our special
education rules now we host that in
rules instead of writing a single
statute for every single procedure we
use but our students and our parents are
relying on those rules that are in place
now so that they know how to access
their free and appropriate public
education so if you make a change like
this in an amendment that was introduced
basically at the 11th Hour in the
session with very little notice you will
be you could be changing it right now or
maybe opening it up for change next year
but with very little uh ability for
parents who are relying on those rules
and students who are relying on those
rules to get their public education to
know what's going to change you've heard
some of the things are going to change
are um the timelines the amount of
notice parents get before could change
the amount of notice parents get before
a meeting the right to have the um
evaluation reports so you can read them
and understand them before you go into a
meeting uh the prohibition on use of
aversives such as uh withholding food to
try and get a student be to behave overh
holding water or using electric shock or
noxious smells those are all practices I
think we could um agree we are poor and
shouldn't be used on any child and
should not be part of special education
why we want to weaken rules because they
don't um exist written down currently in
our statutes this should not be done
this amendment is in expedient to
legislate I can't speak to the other
parts of the amendment because I don't
got time to read them through you got to
give us time this is not the way we
should be making laws um I understand
that the writers of the amendment worked
with some parents but there are many
parents there are 30,000 students in our
Public Schools who are getting special
education services and they all come
with parents and families who are
supporting them they all should be heard
before anything like this is passed and
I guess I'm going to wrap it up now
because my time is up but we oppose this
amendment and it really should not be
pushed through thanks Deborah are there
questions from the
committee not see you thank you okay I
like call forward Becky Wilson
good morning chairman lad members of the
committee almost good afternoon thank
you for uh sitting through so much
testimony today I will try not to repeat
things that have already been said uh
for anyone who does not know I'm Becky
Wilson I'm the director of governmental
relations for the New Hampshire school
boards Association uh we are opposed to
this amendment I will steer clear of the
section five I think that that's been
probably talked about enough today um
however we feel this amendment in
general is not needed in our opinion at
a minimum we would Advocate the changes
especially some that are so substantial
as what is contained in this amendment
should be considered as a whole once the
full special ed audit is completed um
there are Domino effects that come with
changes to special ed rules and or any
rules to for that matter and knowing
that there is an active audit going on
right now and seeing that just this one
section produced 188 Pages worth of
information I think it is um too quick
to be able to put into place something
that should be the end of a pro process
and changes to the end of a process
before any of the other information has
come out about the other aspects of the
audit um in addition we would say that
the majority of information mentioned in
this amendment is already available
publicly for data in terms of looking at
indicator data at the district level
every district is audited on 17 special
Le data points every single year there's
a state performance plan you can look at
every single District in terms of these
17 indicator data um and those include
things like parent involvement um
disproportionate representation child
find find transition hearing requests
and how they were resolved mediation
agreements um results of due process
hearings are also available online with
information that is redacted so I'm not
sure what information is missing um that
would be needed I think that was our
other concern in terms of this amendment
um it doesn't talk at all about what it
says personally identifying information
including but not limited to so what
what is included um I think anybody who
has seen a student's IEP I think
somebody mentioned previously their
child's IEP was something like 20 Pages
it's not uncommon to have students who
have a 30 or 40 page IEP quite honestly
with really extensive information um
outlining family situations medical
diagnosis um history of evaluation data
that can go back many years um even in a
current IEP you may have at least the
previous three years information in
there if not more than that um
situational information about families
and how that's impacting the child's
ability to be successful at school or
not um there's a lot of personal
information so I'm not sure what else um
would be available to the office of the
special ed Advocate uh if a parent goes
to the office now they can give parental
consent for The Advocate to look at
their child's IEP so that's already in
place um so have I'm not sure what would
be in theou as well I think we heard a
little bit about maybe what the
intention was of theou but uh for
leaning on any of the experience of
developing M us the last couple of years
around Special Ed I think we've seen how
difficult that process can be and how
confusing theou can be we still are
having challenges with Charter School M
us and special EDS so I think theou idea
is concerning uh lastly this amendment
doesn't mention at all the specialed
policy and procedures manual that has to
be housed at every single District that
outlines the district levels processes
for special ed all of the policies that
are in place in that District it is
specific to the district so if you're
looking at what local districts are
providing for alternative options those
should already be outlined in there the
majority of those are available uh
online publicly so um I I think we would
support the idea of putting together
some sort of committee to look at all of
the results of the special ed audit and
look at how to sort of back into some of
these decisions that are being made um
and to take into account things like
District actions where the district is
required to file for due process as part
of the special ed rules and when the
district is not able at any level to to
file for due process there are specific
decisions where the district has to take
action either way um there are also
situations where there can be a
disagreement um that doesn't require a
resolution that is in the rules there
are some things where you just agree to
disagree that is outlined in the special
ed rules I'm concerned about the
language um in the amendment talking
about resolution and whether or not
things have been resolved is it really
looking at resolution or is it looking
at satisfaction with the resolution
result because there are very few times
but there are times where a resolution
might not be satisfactory to a parent or
to a district that's understandable I
think we heard a lot of those situations
when we're talking about developing this
office in the first place um but you
know that that there's a big difference
between something being resolved and
somebody being satisfied with the
results of that resolution thank thank
you very much further questions from the
committee yes representa Dr thank thank
you thank you for taking my question um
I'm looking at page uh two at the bottom
where it says to assist in the
Fulfillment of the duty to prepare this
annual report um they were asking for
the reports generated on the databases
so I feel like that's a a direct answer
to a specific need in here so why would
you not support that uh thank you for
the question representative dry first of
all I'm not sure what other databases
any databases other than nessus would be
applicable um the process um procedures
complaints Etc is outside of the office
of special ed at the department it has
nothing it's actually run in a totally
different uh department at the
Department of Education so I'm not sure
what reports or databases they're
maintaining but the outcomes of due
process hearings are posted online at
the
department thank you further questions
from the committee yes representative
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
being
here could you comment in light of what
you said about um a lot of this
information already being available if
you look at page one of the bill lines
25 and then going from there to page two
line six so those I think four bullet
points are all of those items already
available it some of that seems familiar
to me already thank you for the question
representative Damon um in response to
the date the date in line 26
every district has to submit a child
count on October 1st and that would
outline exactly how many students are
identified and in what categories so
this date could be adjusted I think to
be more representative of an actual
snapshot of the current year if it were
October 15 even November 1st because
you're going this September 1st data
would be pulled from the previous year's
identification so that doesn't make a
lot of sense to me but yes that is
available already um the PE the number
of kids in each category and grade level
yes that's already
available um expenditures are available
um I know there's other legislation
already as well about announcing or
posting your expenditures and what you
received from the Department in terms of
idea funds um and annual progress on the
state performance plan as I said is all
available by District online for 17
different special ed indicators thank
you yeah we have those idea indicators
especially Part B number five where we
it gives you the three categories of
weighted IEP we received that in
accordance what Becky just said we do
have the department here that if we have
specific questions now we can ask we've
gone through all the public cards that I
have but we have the department uh
technical assistance is there to provide
we have Liz Brown and Rebecca fette Liz
being the attorney one of the attorneys
and and Rebecca being the director um is
does the committee
okay could uh a Becky not a Becky you're
off the hook here thank you very much uh
so I don't know if you're coming up to
Dian on this
one got a whole
crew do you need another chair
there it's just easier if we all come up
we'll be able to answer questions for
you um my name is Rebecca fet I'm the
state director of special
education I'm Liz Brown I'm Council for
the um and Department I'm also in charge
of the administrative rules process
which I think can be helpful in this
conversation we have your two cards but
Diana we need yours I will get you a
card uh for the record Diana Fenton
attorney with the Department thank you
if I could go through and just clarify a
few things that might save some
questions um so I'm not going to talk
about five I'm going to leave that to
Liz she's going to talk to you about
five um most of the language that's in
here including um the first paragraph
Was language that was in the statute
already so for the first change that
we're asking for this was something that
said the district had to in writing
notify the department of refusals and
what we did was we said we already have
this information in nessus we're already
able to pull this information that's an
extra step for them to have to in
writing notify the department so we
changed that so so that we would pull
the report from nessus so we would know
how many rejected IEPs or partially
rejected IEPs um and then would pass it
on so that we could P we could send
information about the different dispute
resolution processes for um school for
parents so that was already there we
were we're just changing the way that it
is reviewed um the we already complete
the we are already required to re
complete a report regarding special
education so the only change in this
that it would be an annual report that
was submitt on September 1st so this is
not it's it's just giving us a date that
we need to um turn this in and then if
you go to page two um line 10 that is
just saying that from section one that
report that we pull on rejections would
be included in the report that's already
being done so that would that's all that
that's
adding for the next one the department
um yep section three about the office of
The Advocate this is something that we
um debated consistently because the
initial request was to have access to
ness's completely and we do not have the
ability to only provide access to
certain things within nessus it is an
old system where we would have to give
her access to all students there are
currently 32,000 active students within
the system and there are
175,000 active and inactive students
within the system so we felt that we
needed to narrow the access to students
um to the ones that she was working with
so that that was what we talked about
for that one and then we were we
willingly before we even came to this
amendment discussed providing reports
from nesses we are able to pull reports
from nessus to provide the data that she
is looking for um to be able to complete
her
processes as I said I'm going to skip
number five and then number six is not
new it is um I believe Mr Beville had
said that it was a new process it is not
a new process it was something that was
brought up um on page 85 of the dispute
resolution process audit where they
asked to um ensure training and
education includes all relevant
requirements for Lea special ed dispute
resolution compliance and Local District
residential uh dispute resolution
options so this was saying if we're
doing those options we want to be able
we want to know what you're doing and we
would want to know what your decisions
were through that and that was something
big that came up um because we don't
know what agreements districts are
coming into with parents um we don't
know any of that and that was something
that came up repeatedly within the
audit I think that I covered everything
that um we there are a couple other
things that have no no um basis on this
conversation but we do every District in
the state does use nessus so every
district has information in in nessus
there are four districts currently that
do not use it as their IEP system so
they have their data which is those
those data points for the indicators
that we are able to pull from there but
we would not be able to pull an IEP
because their IEP is at the district
level it literally says in some of the
sections C file so it's not an official
document so there are four districts
that currently do not use our system for
their IEP every other District in the
state does use our system for their IEP
so that was all of them except five and
I will answer any questions on all of
them except five yeah I I have a
question for you then Becky before we go
to some of the others why are there four
districts that are not using our system
they feel that it is cumbersome that it
is Antiquated that it is difficult to
use um and they are not required to use
it except for the data point we actually
have a sheet that we provide to them
that says these are this is the
information that you must put into the
system so that we can collect the data
that we need to report on our indicators
is there any accountabilities do you
have a hammer of any kind um we do go
out and monitor districts and we do look
at files um for those districts we they
have to actually provide any
documentation to us um so and we
actually would have to go to their
District to see those files if they
weren't able to submit them to us so we
through our monitoring process we do go
out and we look at their files and we do
look at their information it just is we
aren't able to do a desk audit from the
Department in nessus because they don't
put that information in
there it sort of answers my question a
bit but I don't carry a hammer I try to
I I guess is there some legal reason why
that they don't want to do this or is it
just because they can't make it work
where they are it's just a difficult and
I would agree with them it is a
difficult system to use it forces you to
be compliant it forces you to do certain
things so that it is compliant and it's
not easy to um navigate if you're not
familiar with
it is that training excuse me we Pro we
provide a lot of training it's it's you
just have to get used to it it's just
it's very systemic and it has very
prescribe things that you can and cannot
do represent Terry do you have a
question yes thank you uh following up
on the four districts is the
identification of the four districts
protected by some sort of privacy
provision or could you name them for us
off the top of my head and then well any
of the four and then could you explain
the choice of September 1st with respect
to line 26 on page one so I I did not
choose September 1st but it's not an
issue for me because we would be
reporting on the previous year's data so
we would have all of the data that we
need to be able to submit that report by
um September 1st most of that data we
have by July 1 so that would give me
because I'm the one that would be
writing the report it would give me from
July 1 to September 1 to write that
report because all of that data is is
read available by that time okay and
with respect to the four districts you
don't know any of them so so you so you
know there are four but you don't know
who they are I know I know the one we
just convinced to move over um I think
that um I I would hate to say I wouldn't
want to say a district that I'm
incorrect on I believe I know a couple
of them but I don't know all four of
them okay so you know that there are
four but you just don't know who they
are right off the top of my head y
interesting other questions represent
miler
yeah my my thank you for being here
you're always welcome here when we're
talking about special education issues
thank you uh my my is a general question
what is the status of the audit right
now and when will it be completed sure
so the special education audit is um
they are continuing to ask us for a
request for information um they're
continuing to send us um rfis or what
they're called and we are at about um
RFI number 17 and they have said that
they believe they be able to um discuss
with us us the report in December um and
then it would be issued after that so um
it is take just the amount of
information that we have it's taking
them longer to review it so it has been
extended out to um when we would be
discussing the report in December so
December is the date yeah they I will
say that they have issued some of their
or um they will be issuing some of their
observations already so we already
received an observation regarding our
state advisory committee and they will
be issuing uh four more observations
this month to us so that we can start to
work on those ahead of um the final
report so they do um issue some things
so that we can start to work on them
right away thank you
yep Andre she thank you and thank you
for taking my question anybody um I'm
gonna ask you again about this page two
at the bottom where in to assist in
fulfillment of the duty to prepare the
annual report so if you could describe
maybe the reason for this paragraph
being in there if the things are online
sure so um this is this could be
information that is not online because
we do have the um nessus database where
we are able to pull aggregate
information and provide it to her we
also have the access database that um is
in the office of governance that
contains all of this this dispute
resolution processes so while you have
all of these specific things we would be
able to aggregate it into one report and
say in the state this is what it looks
like you're welcome um and Diana just
reminded me we had asked about rule
making um so we do have rules that are
coming up next year we have rules that
are coming up the year after we have
rules that coming up the year after so
they don't all expire at the same time
but they are expiring gradually over the
next few
years for Special
Education First bets yeah yes representa
luno thank you very much Mr chair um and
thanks for being here today to uh to
take some technical questions um with
respect to sections 1 and six how does
the department um
presently enforce um the process and
timelines when it comes to dispute
resolutions and uh talking about both
both Department U processes and um and
dispute resolution that may be taking
place through the um through the the Lea
through the the local school
district um So currently we are working
on processes for this um the for for
section one we had not been doing this
um we had not been collecting rejections
from districts and nor had the office of
governance neither office had been
collecting this um and so we have
started to develop that process of how
we would be pulling the reports and what
we would be doing to meet that
obligation um for six as I said that has
always been in there but it has always
been a may and or is encouraged to so we
never asked for dispute resolution plans
from leas nor had we ever asked them
what um decisions had been made within
their districts regarding dispute
resolution so those are both processes
that we would be working on we have our
one of our technical assistance centers
coming this summer to work with us to
fine-tune all of our processes and
ensure that we're meeting all the
requirements around dispute resolution
so follow up on that yes so so thanks so
so do you do you actually need state law
to um for the Department to to
um enforce the you know existing you
know policies do you need state law to
you know to implement you know good
management
practices uh you know are I guess what
why is the department
waiting why why can't the department
just go ahead and put in good management
practices so I don't think the first um
you are referring to one and six I don't
think the first one is a management
process it was we are changing it so
that it's not something the districts
have to submit to us in writing we're
going to pull it electronically because
it had been the districts are the onus
was on the districts and we're taking on
the responsibility and saying we're
going to pull that report and we're
going to do it internally rather than
expect the districts to plan send it to
us so that's what the change is in the
first one it's not really manag IAL it's
more of we're going to change who's
responsible for that process and ensure
that that process is done for the second
one
um I think that we in discussions with
the Auditors I think that it was felt
that we needed to um ensure that what
was going on in districts was happening
but this I'm going to let Diana refer to
this one I
think thank you I think and the audit
even says this is that historically the
department has not played a very AG Rive
active role and so in doing so and and I
mentioned during the audit review here
that we had a very robust discussion
with the Auditors about their position
that the department had more authority
to oversee this area of local school
districts than historically the
department has played and so this change
of language uh addresses that and allows
the department to do
that so Diana I I I'm still trying to
Grapple with the the question that
myself and represent Terry addressed
these four districts you have oversight
as a department over special education
in those schools as well and if the
special education Advocate is going to
have to go individually to these schools
and I don't know whether there's a paper
file or what they're doing there uh to
obtain information it seems to me
there's something not right here if if
we're allowing well you decide whether
you want to be part the database or not
um is that a a decision is being made by
our doe or is it being made by local
control it's either the rule or the
statute says that they may use it they
are not required to use it and that's
why we don't we can't enforce them
putting in all of their IEP
information they may use the database
yes and then there are Point data points
that they must enter in but they it's
only a may use the database so it's not
like the unique uh like the pupil
identifier where they're required to put
individual data in this is a separate
system yes yes I understand that then
why don't we have the same rules for you
participate here you're also going to
have to participate here it's because
statute we blown it it it says may
that's why then that's what's always
been the cas is that it's May so nessus
is created by Ru making and part of it
is mandatory which is a sh and part of
it is a May so there are certain data
points that they must report and there
are others that they may report and so I
want to follow up on the special so
under the IED indicator number five
where you have the three categories
Becky you know what I'm talking about do
they report that information to you yes
they report that in nessus that would be
one of the data points that we require
them to put into the system so that we
can collect that data so that is through
um the placement page for the IEP and it
would be the services page for the
students so that information must be put
into the into the system so that we can
calculate that data so are they using
this system partially part for those
data pieces that we need yes they are
partially using it because they all must
turn in the data and they and that's how
we collect the data is through
nesses okay further questions from the
committee it sounds like they have
access they know how to use it but
they're choosing not to use it for this
right and many of them pay for another
system to of those four I believe they
pay for another system to use so there
are other systems out there not necess
that they can use to do their
paperwork okay any other questions for
the Department do you want she's going
to talk would you like would you like me
to address yes absolutely from the legal
side yes so um I have one point on the
moou that I think I just want to make
sure before I get to five so um it would
be oneou that we would have between our
agency and the special education
Advocate agency which is a separate
agency the fact that we have M with
other agencies when we do data sharing
is just how it's done I think we have
about 10 m with the Department of um
DHHS for different data that we we share
and it is to protect that data and is to
make sure that it is clear between the
two agencies because we are separate
agencies how that data is going to be
utilized how that data is going to be
protected and what precautions are going
to be put on that data it's standard
practice there would be oneou we're not
talking about multiple M us for every
parent that the special education
Advocate might be trying to assist I
think that's an important thing that was
discussed a few times here and I just
want to make sure standard practice we
have many M us with many other agencies
DHHS being one of the most common that
we have many data sharing agreements
with any questions about that before I
deal with number five which pretty much
took up our morning we do represent B
bony
um thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um so you just
mentioned that that that data sharing
that personal information could be
shared now the special education
advocate office is an independent agency
outside of the department so there has
been legislation uh going through right
now that talk about the sharing of
personally PB Pi information and that
parental consent is required um could
you just speak to that for
me so um thank you for your question um
it is that legislation that is currently
pending and now my computer is 1690 is
completely a brick because that's how
long the battery lasted um we would have
the that would be one of the things that
we would have to make sure that we
covered if that law it's ought to pass
so it probably does we would have to
make sure that we have determined who um
has the burden of notifying the parents
that that information
is going to be um shared and that is a
that is a um point that we have had uh
conversation that we have had with the
special education advocate in getting
here so there was a lot of conversations
when I I think when representative
cordelli said this is like maybe draft
10 or 12 that is accurate and that that
law that um legislation that is
currently pending was one of the factors
that we discuss because we want to
anything that we do now and we create
that data sharing would have to be
consistent with all all data privacy
laws all the ones that already currently
exist as well um which includes the ones
under 189 which is sort of one of my
niches there at the department um
because we have to make sure that we
have a report that
indicates every time that our data has
been accessed so that's we have a
reporting obligation for that so it's a
little bit different than the
legislation that's going through but
it's also something that we would have
to make sure that our would cover and
make sure that we're complying with all
of the laws that's the reason if you
think about why we need M us is because
there's lots of different facets of laws
and information that has to be protected
and thatou is a way that the two
agencies can come together and make sure
that we are doing it in compliance with
all of the applicable laws does that
answer your question thank you are there
further questions from the committee yes
represent Miler thank you thank you Mr
chair um I guess I have a concern you
know we've have we have this
report which you're very familiar with
and you have an audit that's
pending what is the urgency for this at
this point in time I I am concerned
about the last minute nature of this not
withstanding the work that's been done
the number of drafts that's been done
but why now I mean why wouldn't we want
to look at the the whole topic of this
at the appropriate time and do this in a
very definitive kind of a way rather
than in the 11th Hour rush it
through why now why can't we why can't
we wait that's my question so
representative Myer um thank you for
your question I'm not sure I'm the best
person to answer that question this was
brought to me as um a bill to look at it
was not something that I know uh I mean
that I was that I that I was aware that
the department was driving I don't
believe we were driving it I think there
were conversations that were had between
attorney Fenton and the special
education Advocate regarding data
sharing um that prompted probably this
bill and so I think that I think the
data sharing was probably what drove it
but I don't know I cannot speak to the
urgency I'm sorry who who who of the
department can answer that question for
me why now I think the short answer
representative Miler is that um the
feeling was wanting to be responsive to
the audit and some of the concerns that
were raised and that was something that
we talked about when we brought this
audit in front of this legislative body
was that uh I think representative lad
brought up the point that there were
some retain bills that could be utilized
to start to address some of these uh
concerns that were raised that was the
disc thank
you okay now if I can try to address um
paragraph five which was honestly not a
provision that I was prepared to speak
on today did not anticipate that this
was going to take up the bulk of the day
um
so we have and and representative belter
very early asked the question of what is
our rul making Authority with respect to
special education the special education
Ru making Authority there's four rsas
that give the department rule making
Authority one is RSA 21 N9 um Ro I uh
one which basically says with we can uh
that uh State Board of Education can um
adopt rules dealing of pro programs
affecting children with
disabilities the second area is under
186 C5 which is for program
approval third is 186 c18 ran numeral 5
gives the State Board rule making
authority to determine for state aid and
the last one and I did them out of order
on purpose is a broad one which is 186
c16 that's rulemaking and it is the
section where this language that um is
in five is getting appended to what I
would call the catch-all phrase at the
end of the statute so we'll talk a
little bit about statutory construction
here because I think that's really
important this
rulle making Authority Under 186 c16
says the State Board of Education shall
adopt rules pursuant to 541a that's the
standard rule we all have to adopt rules
under and consistent with the provision
for a free appropriate public education
relative to and it enumerates a long
list of things one developing individual
educa individualized education programs
two approving and monitor special
education programs three reporting a
number of children with disabilities in
school districts four requesting
administrative due process hearings and
appealing a final administrative
decision Roman numeral five determining
eligibility for participation in
approved programs Roman numeral six
appointing surrogate parents Roman
numeral 7 determining the length of the
school year for children with
disabilities and then we finally get to
Roman numeral 8 which is the catchall
which is where we spent all day talking
it says other matters related to
complying with the provisions of this
chapter it's a catch up now remember
every rule that we go to to gel car we
have to cite what our statutory
Authority is so sitting back there I
went and did a quick search where is the
only times that we ever rely upon y86
c16 Roman numeral 8 in our rule making
our current Ru making we do it
twice one is the definition of parent in
rule
11204 and and so that in a
definition the second place is um in
13.12 it's the only other time that we
site to it in that one it's a rule
dealing with Personnel for special
education programs in addition to this
catchall provision that we used there is
a three different Federal cfrs that are
cited for our rule making Authority for
that Personnel rule so this catchall
provision is really only used once ever
so when the amendment says that we're
going to when we use that catchall that
catchall has to be limited to it can't
exceed state or federal minimum
requirements unless the rule is
specifically authorized by Statute this
is a tiny tiny exception we have many
1100 rules and we really never Ed this
exception so the all the discussion
you've heard today from the parent
groups that feel that their all of the
rules are going to get destroyed because
of this language being appended to the
catchall phrase at the end are
misconstruing the statute and are
misconstruing statutory construction
rules of how we are how how you draft
statutes and how the attorney fitt and I
interpret the statutes that are drafted
I think it's a really important point
that this is the catchall at the end
this is a very tiny very tiny part of
the rule making Authority that the
department has and has really only been
used twice in the history of our 1100
rules so I think that kind of EX sets
the tone for how narrow this addition is
and is why when I read this I wasn't
focused upon this language as changing
much of anything in our rules because
this isn't something that we are using
and I was more focused when I was
looking at this proposed legislation
making sure that I was protecting the
data privacy of our special education
students that were in our system and
trying to make sure the special
education Advocate had the tools that
she needed to be able to do her job
because that's what I was hearing her
frustration was that she didn't think
she had the tools and she felt like she
needed certain aspects of this so this
is why we were not focused on this
language and um and so it's a I think
that's a kind of I think if you
understand the rul making process I
think it's really important to remember
that we have to cite statutory Authority
every time we adopt an administrative
Rule and we are not relying upon this
very small exception I'm happy to answer
any questions if I've confused anyone
tried not to um the ru making process I
believe is a laborious process and it's
very detail oriented um and I think it's
very important when we are talking about
statute that we are focusing on the
actual language on the page and not
allowing a very a catchall at the end of
a very specific statute authorizing the
State Board of Education to adopt
numerous different categories of rules
to allow a very small part catchall at
the end basically wipe out all of the
other statutory Authority the department
that the State Board of Education I
should not misspeak the State Board of
Education has with respect to rul making
thank you
represent
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you all
for being
here
um so I need some either repeated or
further
explanation Miss Brown from sometimes I
don't yeah okay you may well have said
it just fine but I have not got it
yet so can I can I help you well let me
ask first
please so lines 1 to three on page
three the only part of that that's
currently in statute correct me if I'm
wrong is the phrase other matters
related to complying with precisions of
this chapter
correct correct so when you indicated a
moment ago that this has only been used
twice
ever that twice ever doesn't include the
drafted language beginning provided and
and through lines two and three great
doesn't that language
considerably uh change the meeting to a
much greater catch-all frankly I'm I'm
reading this from my prior experience
kind of like the end of a job
description and other duties as may be
required which means we can tell you we
have to do anything which pretty much
explains how I ended up here today um
sorry I'm the only one that laughed at
that
joke um
so the catch all as
written could be super broad but even as
super broad it's not being
utilized so adding this language would
re would restrict the number of times
that that the agency could rely upon
this other matters relating to special
education but it doesn't change any of
the other existing rules that we have
that all the parent protection all the
due process all of the other the things
that would that people were saying if
you if you put this in we're going to
lose our ability to have our current
rules the other rules have separate
statutory Authority and they are
authorized by separate statutory
Authority if you go through the 1100
rules at the bottom of the 1100 rules
you'll see a table you don't and I can't
even show at the at the bottom and for
each individual rule it will map to what
the statutory Authority is for us to be
for the um state board to be able to
adopt that rule if we can't link it to a
statute we can't get it through Jael
car yes go
ahead thank
you
so if this section five lines 1 to three
were to become
statute then would it be correct that
that could then be used as a rationale
for any rule no it's not correct
because the all the we
have four
different rules that allow us to to have
rule making
Authority this is if you read it in
context 186 C 16 has a list of statutory
Authority that's independent of Roman
numeral number
eight go ahead she speaks lawyer speak
and I sometimes don't um so what what
we're saying is that the only things
that fall under number eight are the
definition of a parent and then
Personnel Personnel every other rule
that we have falls under those other
categor above eight they all relate to
those other categories they do not
relate to this
one and that
language that they're tacking on only
relates to eight because that's how
statute that's statutory construction
you can't take language at the last
sentence and make it change one to S if
you took that clause and you put it in
the introductory paragraph before that
list
the one to one to Roman numeral 8 then
that Clause would modify one to eight
but because it's only in eight it only
modifies
eight that's just a a statutory
construction rule
if Luna yeah thank you thank you Mr
chair and thank you um uh attorney Brown
for for that but um but I I guess um you
know Roman 8 talks about Provisions in
this chapter and the chapter isn't 16
the chapter is 186c right that's the
chapter the chap the chapter is defining
special education right 186 186 or
186c which one is the
chapter 186 C 186 C so eight
Roman 8 refers to all of
186c and I and and I I guess
notwithstanding your interpretation of
this but would would another lawyer
potentially have a different
interpretation of the um of of how the
the the the new language language in
bold uh the part that begins with
provided in no case uh shall could
another attorney interpret um the
applicability of that different
different from how you've interpreted
that there's always a lawyer on the
other side that's right respect thank
you for your question but I mean I I
don't I I think it's a bit of a trick
question yes of course there's always a
lawyer that's going to argue something
different but I think it would be
against the general cannons and tenants
of statutory construction no no I I I I
appreciate that um but but it isn't that
what we're hearing from from from people
today that they don't want to be subject
to an attorney who might look at
this 10 years from
now and say hey you know what that
applies to all of 186c I mean could
could you could you you know empathize
with that
concern uh thank you for your question I
I don't think that's a correct
interpretation I think it would be a
very contorted reading of this statute
um especially in light of the
existing administrative rules and the
number of other statutes that we are
citing for Authority that has nothing to
do with the rule making authority of the
State Board under Roman numeral
8 statutory construction representative
bone well thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question question um
then my question is if it only pertains
to those two categories that you're
talking about uh parents and Personnel
why is it in
here um thank you for your question
um I I didn't you mean the existing
Roman numeral eight why is it
there
um respectfully I'd have to go back to
the statutory history um and and see
what was thought of when it was put
there it looks like the last time the
statute was looked at was in 2009 and I
was doing corporate and commercial law
back then so I I apologize I I don't
know why the catch all was was put there
respectfully sorry not much help are
there further questions represent
leus thank you for taking my question
and for trying to make this clear to
us
um I'm looking at the first word in that
sentence of Roman numeral 8 which says
other matters and when it says other
matters does that mean other than Roman
numerals 1 through 7 and so that's why
it
is pertains just to eight um thank you
for your question represented like
because that's how I read this is
because there are seven specifically
enumerated categories and then it number
eight is other matters that maybe we
haven't specifically enumerated is
exactly how I read
this thank you further further yes
represent
whitcock good afternoon good afternoon
thank you for waiting around CL and
Clarity um I would follow up on
represent L's question about the
attorney versus attorney obviously this
morning we've heard multiple who did had
a different concern of parents concern
um taking your interpretation as
accurate and taking the fact you said
this is only been used twice basically
this
provision why is the new addition even
in there why why is why is this portion
that's causing so much um discontent
it's only used such a rare time in
past um thank you for your question
representative Woodcock again um I'm not
sure that I can answer that um like I
said this was not a provision that I
focused on I was really uh focusing upon
the data privacy issues and trying to
get the special education Advocate the
information that she needed and when I
read this I just did not see that it was
a significant change okay um in the law
and that's how I viewed it that's fine
open that M chair yes so to the chair
repr Mr F do you or
represent um neither one of us proposed
these we were asked to work
we were asked to work on these um they
were presented to us by The Advocate and
representative cordelli so we were asked
to work on these and give our provide
our input for them so I don't know where
um I believe that Advocate um and I
can't say her last name either I believe
Kristen had said um that she she and U
representative cordelli had conversation
with parents but that would just be me
repeating what she had said Thank you
thank you Mr chairman are there
questions yes represent Miler thank you
Mr chair not to belay with this point
but uh just an observation
uh uh attorney Brown while while you
were speaking about your uh item 11
there it was interesting as I was
watching the crowd behind you I had some
people going like this other people
going like this which is an indication I
think of the complexity of what we're
talking about here then just a comment I
think one of the dilemmas that I I felt
this morning as I was listening to the
uh testimony was the question of
trust trust about the language and how
it can be interpreted by those parents
who are
fearful of uh losing something that they
currently have and I don't know how you
deal with the qu in my mind the question
of trust without the engagement of more
people involved in the creation of the
language particularly as it relates to
the and I I've said this a couple times
this morning I'm very concerned about
the audit and the pending results of the
audit and clearly the issue of what this
committee has heard throughout my 12
years here anytime you deal with the
issue of special education because
you're dealing with parents you're
dealing with kids you're dealing with
relationships the relationships that
start prechool that move all the way
through and that's a very tenuous kind
of a situation where you're trying to
have parents and the and an institution
that provides services to students and
and it's so important for the future of
their children and so my uh my concern
is the last minute thing here without
the without the uh opportunity for the
engagement and I know that engagement is
very difficult but in the end if the
engagement is there and there is some
sense of understanding what those
changes need to be to comply with this
audit or the pending results of the
other audit it just seems to me that
this this bill is premature at this
point in time because we haven't had
that kind of Engagement and I appreciate
your being here and trying to provide
some clarity for us thank you very much
any further comments from the
committee thank you very
much with that I'm going to close this
hearing okay
and and I do appreciate your work in
trying to do this I do because it's
important
this yeah
we're let's take a half hour
break I got to
[Music]
get we're going to take a half hour
break
make
that okay for members of the committee
we're going to take a half hour break
here then we're going to come back and
address 378 first and
340 I've got it right here I just got it
this
morning yeah that there's been a lot of
inter all right there's been a lot
of
e
e e
we're going to open up the exec session
for SB 378 so we're probably streaming
now for the okay for the information of
the committee we had another amendment
which the subcommittee was working off
it's 1679 H which you should have in
your folders which we had and what has
been done
subsequently multiple visits with doe
and with the L legislative Services
across the way they found several areas
that needed Corrections so there was
another amendment made which says 1898
H and what I've done on 1898 i' made
another copy highlighting and bold those
areas which are
changes and I'll just take you right
through it comparing the amendment we
were given last week and this amendment
right here and where the changes are are
compared to the
two but where is represent
Heath you're going to call okay okay
okay good let's let's go ahead and start
then on on this bill
378 this is a bill that deals with a per
U BL blah blah performance-based
accountability system which we have we
have the input system and the
performance system which we measure and
the PBS pbas needs some refine we've
been talking about a task force to do
that on on the amendment on on line
7 through n that remains unchanged from
the amendment you saw the other day it's
the same there is hereby established a
task force to develop and review the
performance-based accountability system
that will serve to demonstrate that a
school is providing the opportunity for
an adequate education has to find in
statute that's there the next line we
had in the uh original Amendment it said
something to this effect right here the
commissioner shall appoint no fewer than
nine and no more than 15 members to the
task force which shall consist of okay
that's been changed now and it says the
task force shall be composed of no more
no fewer than 10 and no more than 15
members and shall consist of now what we
took out of there uh as a member of the
task force we had the commissioner
design who shall select the chairman of
the task force that's been deleted
that's gone we talked about that in the
subcommittee so you'll see the first a
on line 12 where it says this is where
it starts the
members six or more individuals who hold
a current New Hampshire certification of
superintendent assistant superintendent
or curriculum administrator there shall
be at least at least one representative
of each of the five New Hampshire school
administrative Association
administrative regions and one Statewide
at large
representative the Statewide regions are
five that are set up by the New
Hampshire school administrator
Association but also that terminology is
used by Homeland Security that's trying
to identify the regions we have in our
state is that correct Nate I believe
yeah that's what Kate Caitlyn told me
Nate okay so going down to the next on B
on line 16 of the new Amendment it says
two individuals who hold a current New
Hampshire certification uh principle um
that was in the original that's in the
original so there's no change there
C uh which is line
17 uh it says two individuals who hold a
current New Hampshire educator license
as classroom teachers one Elementary one
secondary who are familiar with the
performance-based
accountability um with performance-based
accountability and work in the role of
classroom teacher in a school that was
also in the First Amendment uh on in
1679 each so there's nothing changed
there going on down it says other
educational experts who whose
understanding of performance-based
accountability and expertise will be a
benefit to the task force duties so if
you add up a B and C 6 22 that's 10 and
then other would be the other five
members so we had from nine through but
we took out we took out the one current
School Board member which could be part
of the other five if you wanted a school
board member it was decided when I was
working with the Department that there's
probably not a whole lot of school board
members are familiar with the
performance-based accountability system
yes so under the explanation you've just
given us in
the well let's wait a second because TS
were now we've moved it we've moved it
further down so now you have before in
this it went to the Department Personnel
shall advise facilitate provide
technical support that's gone and we've
tried to put on what are the
responsibilities of doe what are the
responsibilities of the task force not
mixing them up throughout so let's go
down the the a new Amendment it says the
Department of Education shall appoint
task force members after consultation
with professional education
organizations and stakeholder groups
with relevant assessment and
accountability expertise we talked about
doing that we wanted the stakeholder
stakeholder groups engaged that now it
has it uh two the department uh on B on
line 25 the department shall advise
facilitate and provide technical support
to the task force as needed that was in
the other Bill U which we
had going on down and and U going for
let's see um I want to make sure I'm not
jumping around here yeah three then you
go down to and you can see on on B it
came from 167 9 was 2A page 1 lines
27-28 that's been scrapped and it's been
put here going on down line 28 okay the
Department of Education shall set the
schedule and call meetings of the task
force as needed to meet the deliverables
of this
section so the chairperson is the one
that's going to be notifying them if you
read down uh when we go further D
support the chairperson in posting
notice and minutes of task force me
meetings as needed to meet the
deliverables of this section so the
Department's there in support to provide
that technical support with the minutes
and
notifications okay going on to page
two of
the so going um top of page two there's
an
e the department shall remember that's
we're still in that category
responsibilities e solicit solicit
public comment and host listening
sessions relative to the pbas proposals
in collaboration with the task force so
it takes the work of these
superintendant or principles or people
are coming as teachers that it's going
to be the job of the uh the department
to solicit that public comment and
they're working in collaboration with
the task force task force say we want to
may have a hearing so they have a
hearing and they invite these people and
but the department will be soliciting
these people other words it won't have
to be the work of that task force itself
task force can say we want to see
anybody wants to come fine going on down
to the responsibilities of the task
force is on page two
here the task force shall have the
following duties this was item three
page 1 line 29 in
1679 the task force shall elect the
chair person that's new that's what we
request to be done all those other items
B through F come from the original
document or the original uh Amendment
but we added in G the task force shall
review and make recommendations of the
applicability and application of the
pbas for Charter Public Schools EST
stablish pursuant to that RSA and
alternative schools that was we
discussed that and we'd like to have
that in there
um H was there already that's not new
that's just coming over from the other
Amendment uh see going on down to line
17 through
20 uh the department May provide stiens
mileage expense reimbursements to
members of the task force established in
the section as well as make expenditures
of other costs associated with the
administration of the taxk force has
determined to be appropriate by the
department that was Roman four on page
two in that other Amendment we looked at
so that's no change is saying the
department will take care of that
mileage and all that for the people
participating in the task
force uh on 21 through
24 the any unexpended funds for the bium
ending June 30th 2025 and each bium
thereafter if this thing
pursues uh in those accounts shall not
lapse and that all that language came
over from the other one so what we're
doing is trying to make sure that it
it's not just stops at June 25 the
appropriation of dollars it can continue
in other
banum on 25 through
2930 um the task force shall develop a
performance-based scoring system which
shall be based on data and indicators
which are already provided to the
department Andor performance measures
that schools are already required to
provide the department under under other
state or federal laws in establishing
the performance-based system the the
task force may consider one or more of
the following data and data and
indicators and that was Romans 6 page 2
in
1679 note that using only the best
available accountability system was
systems system was deleted as we asked
that that occur so that flipped over in
there and we took out um everything else
on page two just comes over from that
other amendment that the subcommittee
talked
about and then the other change is
starts on line four on page three the
performance-based school accountability
system ver verification process that's
already in statute but we're amending it
to read uh uh RSA 193e 3D to read as
follows um um and it's down below and we
Chang the uh RSA reference not to four
but to Roman 8 as it is now in this
amendment so those changes it's it's
clean up from both OS and from the
Department
yes so I was curious with the phrase
needed as needed I
saw oh I'm sorry yes so I'm curious
with respect to the two mentions at the
very least of as needed and as needed on
page one and I'm going to surmise by
what I read on line three of Page Three
that the as needed is all deliver is is
driven by the report due date of no
later than June 30th 2026 well would
that be correct on page 26 on page one
lines 26 and 27 where it does end up as
needed
the Department of Education shall and
then if the committee says we need to
have input from students or we need
input from teachers in the field as
needed in other words it may not be
clearly then they're going to have to do
it because it's a need of the task
force yes I understand and and clearly
all this is driven by the due date of
June 30th 2026 if it was if it was June
30th
2075 uh as needed could be work can
expand to fill the time allotted so
everything is driven by June 30th 2026
the second question is can my limited
life experience in non-governmental
entities task forces were dismissed at
when they completed their task is there
any dismissal to this task force once it
completes its task or is this a task
force that is in business in perpetuity
the initial part of of developing this
program yes and then continuing yes
to to because the reports they they will
be looking at and saying how do it go
after the first year the second year the
third year are there any issues that we
have to move forward either with
legislation or with recommending or
finding so we find is that correct
Nate yeah come on up to the mic so he he
Nate is out of the doe and this is his
baileywick so to my question with
respect to there is no termination date
for the task force they will continue
until whenever yes there's two different
pieces to this so the first part is
making recommendations for what the pbas
needs to look like yes the second piece
there's additional statutes that aren't
actually part of this amendment that are
just current statutes that require the
department to make um recommendations
for legislation relative to PBS so we
would want some form of this task force
to continue on to evaluate how what they
create in this version is uh impacting
schools Community School leaders um one
of the things that we would expect from
this task force is a recommendation in
statute of how that task force would
then continue on would there be term
limits for different members would be a
different size of a task force maybe you
need a smaller version of this initial
one so I would expect that to come as
part of The Proposal from this task
force as to how does the uh new
iterations of the task force continue on
after their work here is done okay so I
understand that this task force is not
uh the final task force that is
envisioned therefore all of these people
that are going to be uh appointed uh the
10 people would understand when they
when they get involved that they're not
signing up for something for the rest of
their lives yes because there will be
another body that will be created as one
of the outcomes of of this task force
work yes okay and ideally there would be
some overlap you'd have some members
from this initial task force that would
continue on but then with the Poss ility
of you know as people step away from the
task force um you have new people come
on board yes thank
you anything else yes represent dry
thank you just continuing on with
that we have pretty specific membership
requirements for the task force and if
there's an iteration of that if that
changes does the statute have to change
it would yes
okay
represent so thanks and and thank you Dr
Green um so um one of the one of
the parts of the existing statute that
this um overs is the every four
years part so uh so the the the statute
and the the the amendment basically says
the task force delivers a product no
later than June 30th
2026 do we should we have anything that
provides that that I mean the task force
continues but there's no sort of like
deliverable
schedule so I think that would be a
recommendation that would come from the
task force um I would argue four years
is probably not the right term um for
new deliverables to come out we make new
school designations every three years so
it may be that every three years when we
run the accountability system we look to
see did it perform the way it was
supposed to is it matching up with the
expectations and intentions of Statute
and Rule and at that point the
department would be looking to make
future recommendations for legislation
and that would most likely be role of a
future task force is on that threeyear
schedule every time we run the system
we' be looking to see is the system
working the way we want it to work
currently for New Hampshire schools
great great thank thanks very much a I'm
seeing that on page two sort of lines 9
1011 um continuous
review is is that sort of where you
where you said so we don't so we don't
lose that idea yeah yeah all right great
thank
you any other questions on on the
amendment because the amendment is the
bill
okay yes thank you and thank you Nate
because I think this looks exactly like
we talked about in um in the subte in
the subcommittee and but much more
understandable than what we talked about
this and there were some loose ends that
uh Benjamin over an OS Bound in in the
called and talked to Caitlyn and Nate
and and they've been Incorporated in
yeah yeah so it all makes sense
hopefully
yes thank you this is the first time
that I've seen a bill reference actual
account numbers I'm looking at line 22
on page
two so can you just give us a little
perspective on that like what those
accounts are and why are we that
specific so those accounts come from the
state budget um those two particular
accounts are the ones that fund the
assessment accountability work that my
office does um the first one is an
education trust fund account it's line
uh 612 at the end of that accounting
string 612 is uh specifically an
accounting line for State assessment
purposes and it's what we use to pay our
state assessment contracts and the
assessment work which is where a lot of
the accountability data comes from and
then the second accounting line there is
7 64 um which is a general fund account
that also funds the assessment and
accountability work of my
office we we have some funds like the
public school
infrastructure and we wanted it non-lps
thing we're also looking at building Aid
types stuff
with the purpose of being used for the
task force in the public school
infrastructure we used to have
contractors which got on the job late in
that uh uh session and the money did not
roll over it and so we ended up losing
that money because it was during covid
and you couldn't find
contractors and so we changed that say
it's non-aps it stays in that fund and
we can continue to use it so that was
the thing right here too that we
continue to have that money available
for the task
force so any other questions for Nate on
this one Dr
Green Dr Green that sounds good I know I
don't have quite the same audiences this
morning but I'm happy to take you know
three hours four hours of questions if
you guys want to stick around
so I think we've been there and done
that okay
so so okay that's that's this paron
me um well well we we have not had a
caucus on this at all and is there
anybody feels they need a caucus in this
one or we just want to roll on some of
the other
stuff on on 378 on 378
378 you want to do a straw in case you
think do we really think we need to
recall Mary on this no no I don't think
so
I think so this is um so what I'll do is
I'll hand the gavl over to represent
cordelli uh thank you Mr chair um this
is um House Bill
378 um and I uh look to the chairman for
a motion yes I like to make the motion
to OTP on
378 second by represent Miler uh further
discussion yes I'd like to amend uh 34
378 uh with Amendment 1898 H
sir I have no no further discussion
discussion represent mil or anything no
no uh any discussion by the committee
are you ready Mar uh seeing none
um no
okay yes
yes okay I just want to I heathan for
Howard heathan for Linda okay Vice
chairman cordelli yes yes representative
leus yes representative
Belcher no representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative Corell yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler yes
uh representative Cornell yes
representative Heath oh I'm sorry this
is confusing she's not here right now
works good no because Heath Howard Heath
Heath is your first Heath his first name
sorry sorry for the confusion okay
representative
Howard yes representative luno yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Bon yes
representative C scen
yes representative Damon yes chairman
lad yes 18 Y is one
nay so you
got okay so I would like to make a
motion yes Mr chairman do you have a
further motion yes I'd like to recommend
for 3 SB 378 otpa Amendment 1898 second
second by representative Miler uh
further discussion by the committee
seeing none Madame
clerk Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus y Representative
beler no representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative Corell yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative Howard yes representative
luno yes representative Woodcock yes yes
representative Hall yes representative
bone yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 18 days one
day hey the blurbs have to be oh I got
write theur consent calendar consent
consent consent okay the blur set be in
tonight so I'll do it in
Keen we take on yeah yeah we we we have
one bill left and we'd like to be able
to take a caucus on this we haven't had
a chance to talk I don't know if you
have
either know that there
[Music]
was on
e
e e
okay we're going to go on and continue
our exec session right now we're on
sb340 and pardon me yeah yeah I yeah
yeah Oh I thought you got her
already we can start handing out the
side
byid just put them up and go either
way okay
these are the ones we got a concurrent
nonconcurrent
we've received five bills that we have
to either concur or non-c
concur or committee
conference
yeah okay okay we'll be
quick okay we good
there's not enough for
mik I took two of these I don't I
need no those are not part of the record
okay then Mike if you don't so we're
going to go ahead now
with
sb340 and I Look to represent cordelli
for a
motion uh thank you Mr chair um I would
like to move a to pass is there a
second so we have a the Motions OTP 340
made by representa cordelli second by
represent
leus representa cordelli uh thank you Mr
chairman uh I would like to move um
ought to pass on an amendment which is
uh number
1927 H that I think everyone should have
at this
point okay represent Cordell has made a
motion to move uh as amendment to
sb340 Amendment 1927 H is there a second
representative Pell seconds the the
motion uh represent Cordell you like to
speak to your motion please uh thank you
uh this is a very simple uh Amendment um
most of the opposition that we heard um
this morning was related to section five
um and in order to uh pass what I think
are the most important sections of this
bill uh this amendment removes section
five represent Pell any further
discussion no any further discussion
from the committee Madam clerk when
you're ready would you please call the
rooll vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
beler yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative Corell yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler no representative Cornell no
representative Howard no representative
Luna no representative Woodcock no
representative Hall no representative
bon no Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no representative
Heath no chairman lad yes ten ten okay
that motion
fails is there another
motion oh yeah yeah yeah excuse me that
was just yeah so Ron
cardelli uh yes I would
um thinkk yeah I we've already have an
OTP motion on the floor I think that um
uh we should support the OTP motion okay
any further
discussion yes yes okay so we have a
motion on the table OTP on
sb340 wa a
minute we motion 101
yeah so okay okay okay we're going with
that Madam clerk will you call the RO
please Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative luus yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative cell yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative Howard yes representative
luno yes representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes representative
Heath chairman lad yes 20 a Zer
a
um I I would like to not have it on
consent um does that require me to
change my vote it would okay um Madam
cler could I change my vote to uh
no okay the vote is what 19 to1 19
to1 consent no no
okay so so that'll go on the docket that
way so and women so who's gonna write
the blur now you know I think we're
gonna have to go back and redo
this
yeah you see the you're you're going to
be writing the
OTP with it not amend
and then you're going to be taking it
off
yeah oh
okay okay all right yeah
okays right
okay so after a consultation with
uh an expert far greater than me um I
will change my vote back to uh ought to
pass yes there you go
Caren do you have an
eraser so chair yes so will there be
will there be one committee report yes
on the on the merits of the bill not the
B all people are voting the same way
there's one committee report right right
and the committee report won't won't
have anything to do with the um the
amendment that just
failed
no it'll just be on the merits of the
bill itself yes thank
you yeah looks like floor me okay so
where we are right
now the OTP motion will move forward
there will be a blur put together
committee report by represent
cordelli and it's not going to go on or
you can calendar on the
calendar it's not on consent right it's
going to be on the regular calendar on
the regular calendar we've had that was
20 nothing okay yeah yes yeah we can do
that yeah so go ahead represent luno
yeah so thanks so I so I think just for
um full transparency here where where
what do you see happening um not in
terms of what what what do you see
happening then on on the floor when this
comes to the
floor I mean this is not on consent it's
on the regular calendar for a
reason probably because there'll be an
amendment that'll be offered onor
there'll be a floor Amendment something
I'll consider yeah yeah okay okay
yeah
y okay so we're done our business with
our two bills we had to exact today we
do have uh before you right here looking
at the clock I don't want to spend a lot
of time on this either
we usually do it right in the general
court room there we have five bills
which will be that are Senate messages
that came to us from the
Senate and we'll work all the way up
from the bottom number which is
1107 the
recommendation this is the Frameworks
bill that we worked hard on and it's one
where I'd suggest that we
consent they've added the every 10 years
up top there
uh that the education department to
Institute procedures for maintaining
upgrading updating and improving
refining the minimum standards Public
School approval and the curriculum
framework so every 10 years that's not a
bad addition seeing we're working off
with some of
our our
um like Health it was what 2006 it was
written and social studies a little
later than that but you know these these
uh minimum standards are getting pretty
old and so we should be doing it every
years anybody oppos to consent okay
that's consent concur concur concur yes
okay uh next one down is
1165 okay this is the one where
here we had the monies for the public
school
infrastructure have been appropriated
through hb1 and
two
and there this year this bu and we
appropriated 10 million dollar Public
School infrastructure that's the access
to safety and all egress and all that of
school
houses the public school infrastructure
commission looks at that makes
recommendations based upon the
applications we receive but then we have
to take that to fiscal and then back to
Governor
Council it seemed kind of ridiculous to
us that we had to take it the fiscal
when it's already been appropriated by
way of
hb1 and what it often times did it
delayed the using this money in a exp
expedited fashion especially during the
summer when we're trying to get all the
work done so but they' changed it where
it's got to go back to fiscal
I guess they don't trust that commission
or the department
so I don't it
it's I don't
know yeah it it's it's probably what we
need to do is Concur and work on a later
date that's the only
change kind of a Mickey Mouse change
don't you
think um same yeah that's right just got
to do something to everything 1305 is
the freedom of speech and Association uh
at public institutions higher education
we got this side by side on page one
when they're talking about um Campus
Community defining that you can see
where it says include students
administrators faculty and staff at the
institution of higher education and
their invited guests the Senate took out
invited guests
I don't have a gutach over
that uh on page
four the next next change is what
constitutes harassment and it's defined
as RSA 188
j16 they put or other applicable state
of federal law or
regulation and just above that too and
there's one above that too yeah and see
the Senate ver version
adds permitted Express
activity
um I've talked to the sponsor of the
bill he's just anxious for this thing to
move forward he thinks this is a a a
positive thing I'm I'm support of of
concurrent
this where where is everybody
else okay all you need is a majority
quum we got to concur on that um next
one I thought there
was what's the next number you have 1665
no I got5 1695 wait a minute it say
separate paper oh there it is underneath
1665 55
55 jeez I got to drive to ke today um
it's one
word
yeah yeah
clearance anybody objecting to
that I'd recommend
concur any really violent objections
that okay and the last one 1695
they changed the one
word within
right within 14
days be informed 14 day four school days
before I don't know just put a little
preposition in front of it huh I'll take
it outes sound better don't know why no
it's there's no there's a definite one
has to be during within those 14 days
when it has to be before those 14 days
yeah yeah yeah can do we know why why it
was switched to 14 days
[Music]
prior when
I I I I I think that doing it before the
14 days provides more
time but within
St to a third part shall be informed
within 14 school days of the release
date so we want somebody releasing the
student assessment materials like a
third
party
um we'd notify them ahead of time
wouldn't we
yeah so you do it at the beginning
through it so that's so
there so
we why why non-c
concur you
on oh that
what does it
mean if student
person just that before you release the
data you have to notify the
parent um there is no beginning of the
school year um yeah there's
no the parent has no since it's federal
law the parent cannot stop the rulings
um so this is basically just a
notification
system no there's no there's no
opting in out because it's under covered
under
purp can you clarify that is this
because um your you're speaking about
the provisions in fpo where they're
allowed to share the
data but exceptions under perp
yes but it also applies to all third
party vendors
still
yeah there's no
notification right right now there's
no yes representative cordelli I'm just
thinking when you testified
the last go around when you said that
the big deal was that it would happen
but they would at least know that it
happened within for you know after it
all yes now this is changed to the
before to be before so it's a totally
different time frame it's a different
time frame
yes I actually like the Senate's
change you're doing it before you're
giving the parent more time
to say I don't want my my child's
information being released to a third
party I thought the parent didn't have
well it could be any could thought
that's what I heard represent cordelli
say this is just a notification it's not
enough that what I heard you say
yes right correct
student personally
identify wish I do you have the laot
book right there for a
second more
stringent I I wouldn't I wouldn't say
stringent it's just an add an additional
requirement that you have to notify
parents
the will still release the information
third part yes but
um but the
notification based on the sentence
version notification for parents will be
at least 14 um at least 14 days prior
right be at the beginning of school
before on a particular day it will will
be shall be 14 school days before so so
what you're saying is that specifically
on 14 days before the release not 15
days not 16 days not 13 days 14 days
exactly it says under the furpa here on
page 503 of your law
books the right to inspect and review
the students education records within 14
days after the day the School receives a
request for access
that's a little different than this part
though doesn't make you can't do what
they're saying they want you to do they
want you to release they want you to
inform the parent 14 days before the Rel
to whom the data was
released yes
so you know your tenses don't match up
14 days before releas to whom the data
would be released will
be ask J if they would in the enrollment
process would they change the tense if
the tense is wrong sure go ahead uh
excuse me um Jen expert 4 um would in
the enrollment process if they found the
tense was wrong it shall be you know was
for
instance uh would that be corrected in
the enrollment
process imp on language
right right like a comma or something
yeah
right yeah that would change it
too so we go to a commen conference over
that I don't know it's not worth it is
it
[Music]
see we have to have these done see we
have to have these report Committee of
conferences go from let's see the 31st
of May through June 6 all
right so so that's the time so we have
to you know have this thing done prior
to the mon can we can we can we ask for
a committee of conference and then C up
the
language at the committee of conference
sure oh yeah yeah that's done all the
time
request that's probably the way to do it
right
now okay everybody good with just going
non-c concur request committee
conference on one the other ones all
concur okay we have one week to get what
uh wayss and means is but other than
that we look
good and they have input on one of those
we want to concur I think we'll convince
in the same
thing yes can I just ask a question so
if this goes to Committee of conference
which one they have to decide which
one's better the within just let's talk
about philosophy rather than
language has representatives from the
house and the Senate right yes four and
three we'll have four and only those
that are on the committee of conference
are those that voted for the
bill so we'd have I'd have to go back
and look
at then it comes back to the house but
they have a choice when they go to
Committee of conference they have a
choice whether to decide the philosophy
of within 14 days rather than 14 days
before they have that choice between
everybody yeah everybody has to sign off
on it good
or else it fails or no okay we've had to
remove people on the committee of
conference before I've done that and
then you get the votes the way you want
it but then you get to the house floor
it's another deal
yeah other than that I think we're done
for the day you can go to the retirement
party e